[Музика]
до
робити
[Музика]
так
робити
[Музика]
радий вітати вас на цій події та
це велика подорож для нас
сьогодні дякуємо, що приєдналися до нас
це буде а
дуже насичений день
наповнений такою дорогою інформацією
учасники horizon europe launch
день в україні я
готовий привітати вас сьогодні тут
тому що той факт, що ми тут
разом означає, що україна досягла успіху
його
прагнути приєднатися до рамок
інноваційність
ну
програмний горизонт
Європи та Євразії щодо цього
платформа ми зібрали інноваторів
вчені
та місцеві органи влади
органи влади члени громади
обговорити
результати та обговорити майбутні пріоритети в
наука та інновації в промисловості
в різних
дослідження та інновації
програми дякуємо за участь і
щоб продемонструвати
що ми готові піти давайте дамо
один одному оплесками
Ну
наш сьогоднішній порядок денний
має
чотири
різні панелі перша
до 12
40 представників
з
ну
науково-освітній сектор
і ну
говоритимуть члени єврокомісії
приблизно
вашої інтеграції україни до
європейські дослідження
простір, тоді ми будемо говорити про нові
горизонти
перспективи для України в рамках цього
блок у нас буде панельна дискусія
між представниками укр
уряду та вчених
і ми поговоримо про
виконання програми та 14 до
14 30 у нас перерва на каву
після перерви поговоримо про
європейські та національні інструменти підтримки
дослідження та інновації
наші колеги з єврокомісії
розповість про нові можливості для
наших учасників
відколи україна приєдналася до horizon europe
після 16
години
україномовні спікери з розм
про нац
інструменти, відкриті для провідних новаторів і
вчених після невеликої перерви будемо
мати фінал
блог присвячений кращим
українські проекти
ну для попереднього
горизонт 2020
програма, тому це дуже насичений порядок денний, тому
будь ласка
йти в ногу з графіком без хронометражу
і
ми будемо
бути в змозі зробити це
у нас буде синхронний переклад
якщо вам потрібно
переклад тепер настав час
візьміть гарнітури
зробити це
щоб максимально використовувати наші
подія
і шановні спікери під час вашого
у виступах робіть короткі паузи і
не поспішайте, так це
синхронний переклад дуже чіткий
і точно ми готові почати
вітаємо всіх, хто приєднався до нас
прямий ефір
ми дуже вдячні тобі
за те, що приєдналися до нас, за інтерес і
інноваційні горизонти
за сміливість
мрія і
досягати успіху
є
велика і успішна подорож
ми починаємо з короткого відео про
новий горизонт
[Музика]
Україна
м
[Музика]
іноземні
b
[Музика]
дякую, ми бачимо, що ми
багато чого досяг, як ми бачимо з цього відео
впровадження
горизонт 2020 і наступний горизонт європа
не тільки допомагає
міжнародне співробітництво, але також допомагає
ми будуємо наші інновації та науку
сектор ну ходімо далі
реалізувати нашу програму в повній мірі
і я надаю слово зам
міністр з питань європейської інтеграції
міністерства освіти і науки
України
олексій куратов аплодисменти будь ласка привіт
Дорогі колеги
європейські колеги
учасники всі, хто приєднався до нашого
подія
запуск дня horizon europe в україні
для мене велика честь відкривати
ця подія, бо для україни це означає
це момент, коли українські вчені
у розробників і новаторів є нов
можливості в рамках одного з
найбільший
програма ЄС
за приєднання україни горизонт європа і
euroasim є дуже важливим кроком
до інтеграції України до
європейський розвиток
простір реалізації програми
створить
хороший стан для прискорення
розвиток України як а
провідний
одна з провідних країн Європи
за
розширення міжнар
ну співробітництво та розвиток і ну
з європейськими країнами і як ти
знаю з відео 12 числа
23 жовтня 2021 року
україна офіційний представник саміту ЄС
угода між
України та ЄС було підписано було підписано
починається
співробітництво україни на
атомної енергії
та участь України в горизонт
Європа, я вітаю всіх, хто зробив
це можливо
і я вдячний зав
делегація
заступник директора з
ну європейська комісія
е-е, відділ підписує правильно, тому вона
погодилися відкрити наші заходи
у складі нашої європейської групи
і наші команди працювали
тісно разом
за наші останні півроку
назустріч
надання Україні можливості
отримати статус асоціації
країна
звичайно
ми маємо багато зробити, але
маємо перехідний стан і з тих пір
2021 рік
у нас була можливість
брати участь у відкритих конкурсах
приєднання
ці програми та horizon europe і
євразійська програма допоможе
залучення укр
наукове співтовариство в
участь в
в
міжнародні проекти
і той факт, що ми маємо
так, разом
мене
з новаторами
ну представники громадського сектору
науковий сектор
значить, що
всі ці програми дуже актуальні
і важливо так будь ласка
дозвольте привітати всіх з
цю подію і бажаю всім вам
великий і плідний
і успішне обговорення велике спасибі
багато
Ну
велике спасибі олексію каратову
заступник міністра
у євроінтеграції міністерства
науки і освіти дякую
дякуємо всім працівникам міністерства за
роблячи це можливим і дозволяючи
українські інноватори впроваджують свої
програми, тому що це все про
інновації, які має відчути кожен із нас
що ми маємо потужні інструменти, які
ми зможемо використати
створити
досягти і реалізувати великі і
неймовірні проекти так
будь ласка, долучайтеся до цих ініціатив
тому що тепер це можливо
завдяки підтримці нашого європ
колеги
тепер у нас є чудова можливість досягти
неймовірні результати
ну звичайно ми
це було б неможливо без нашого
європейські партнери
і
я надаю слово
до
доброго ранку всім
Ох, велике спасибі заступнику міністра
міністр ну
шановний генеральний директор шановний
представники української науки
та жінки інноваційної спільноти
панове
горизонт європа в україні
Я не можу погодитися з назвою
ваша подія
і я б навіть додав
пора україні бути на горизонті
європа також
як деякі з вас, можливо, знають, що я головний
переговірник для Horizon Europe та
Євразим
дослідження
і технічна програма
і я вів переговори про асоціацію
Україна
до обрію європа і європа
дослідницька та навчальна програма
тому я був свідком цього на власні очі
відданість української влади
зробити
це трапляється
і це явно окупилося, оскільки сьогодні ми
можна відсвяткувати офіційний запуск у
Україна обох дослідницьких програм ЄС
я знаю, що під час пандемії с
ще один варіант насувається попереду
ці непрості часи крихкої економіки
відновлення кажучи про дослідження і
нововведення може здатися віддаленим
навіть без зв'язку з реальністю
однак дослідження та інновації знаходяться на
серце цього
у нинішній кризі дослідження ЄС
і інноваційні програми є потужними
інструменти
залучати наукові спільноти, але
також промисловості, включаючи МСП і
стартапи
дивитися вперед і знаходити рішення
численні поточні та майбутні виклики
Україна
є новачком у дослідженнях ЄС
інноваційні програми
ви були пов'язані з обома горизонтами
Програми atom r t 2020 і минулого року
як горизонт 2020 закінчується ми розраховуємо майже
320 українських учасників
яка отримала понад 45 мільйонів євро
при цьому україна найактивніша
країна Східного партнерства та
займає 7 місце
серед 16 країн
пов'язані з горизонтом 2020
крім того, показала Україна
хороший послужний список у розщепленні
і зони синтезу програми uraturn
де українські суб’єкти поступово
збільшили свою участь у
Європейська дослідницька та навчальна діяльність
дивлячись на майбутнє, яким ви є зараз
приєднання до найамбітніших
транснаціональні дослідження та інновації
програма
який коли-небудь створювався за допомогою майже
мільярд років бюджету на наступний
сім років
порівняно з попереднім програмним горизонтом
У 2020 році це означає збільшення бюджету
30 відсотків
тут я хотів би приділити хвилину
пригадайте цілі horizon europe
це наш головний інструмент для зміцнення наших
науково-технічна база
розробляти рішення для більш здорового життя
стимулювати цифрову трансформацію та боротися
зміни клімату для нашого колективу
стійкість
я дуже хотів би це підкреслити
аспекти
35 з бюджету внесок
кліматичні цілі
тому зелений і цифровий переходи
ядро ДНК цієї програми
урант
програма доповнює досягнення в
цілі Horizon Europe, такі як
перехід енергії, але також
у забезпеченні постійного вдосконалення
ядерна безпека безпека та радіація
захисту в тому числі в мед
промислові та космічні дослідження
я визнаю, що у мене великі очікування
України в найближчі роки
і насправді я б звернувся до аудиторії
сьогодні вчені-новатори
компанії, дослідники, але також
національні контактні пункти міністерств
та українських науково-дослідних установ до
спираючись на цей багатий минулий досвід, щоб
скористайтеся можливостями, які пропонує
наші нові європейські програми
і мені приємно бачити це сьогодні
порядок денний індивідуальний
принести
інформації для світлих умів в
україни, щоб вони могли скористатися
різні частини горизонту і
урат
я сподіваюся, що ви надихнетеся на
свідчення, які ви збираєтеся почути
сьогодні
я можу лише заохотити вас запитати
запитання, зокрема до моїх колег
збираються представити різні сфери
програми eu r і i
дозвольте мені виділити лише деякі з основних
компоненти, як ви знаєте, горизонт в
божественне поділяється на три осн
стовпи
і перший стовп приходить до Європи
сприятиме прикордонним дослідженням
тоді як Європейська дослідницька рада та
здатність талантів, поки вони одружуються
sklodowska кар'єрні дії
Європа Україна показала помітні результати
ну в цих молекулярних реакціях
в минулому
і в останні роки горизонту 2020
насправді ви виграли грант erc i
вірю, що ваш грантоотримувач erc представить
пізніше сьогодні
другий стовп зосереджений на суспільстві
виклики для нашого клімату та
цифрові амбіції він має шість тематичних
кластери та пріоритети та включає
спеціальні інструменти, такі як
партнерства та місії
вам буде представлено ці
інструменти пізніше сьогодні, і це
справді область, де я візьму a
особистий інтерес бачити збільшення
українська участь
нарешті родючий присвячений
інновації для забезпечення ринкової оптики
наукові світлі ідеї
це, наприклад, роль
Європейська рада інновацій, яка буде
запропонувати новий тип підтримки малим і середнім підприємствам
стартапи
по-новому
Я знаю, що Україна запустила свій власний
стартовий фонд, тож чекаємо цікавого
взаємодії
і не забуваймо уратум україна
традиційно добре справляється з фьюжн і
дослідження зору
і не забуваймо, що новий
Програма більше зосереджуватиметься на неенергетичних
таких програм, як медичні та ми
шукати найближчі енергії з
програма horizon europe, зокрема через
кластер охорони здоров'я та місія проти раку
і нарешті картини не було б
без підтримки, яку надає
спільний дослідницький центр
гарантувати, що україна продовжує діяти розумно
дорожні карти спеціалізації
передача технологій і переваги від
важливі послуги, які надає
grc ви почуєте більше
протягом сьогоднішнього дня
пані та панове, ви зараз є
вступаючи в нову фазу вашого
участь у ваших програмах ви
на трамплін для досягнення нових висот
і нових успіхів
я зараз оголошую горизонт європою і
Євразійські дослідження та інноваційні програми
офіційно офіційно запущено в
україно всім удачі і дякую
тобі дуже
ну дуже дякую
за програму дякую за ух близько
співробітництво між україною та ЄС і
країни-партнери і дякую
за фокусування на науці та інноваціях
дякую за таку велику підтримку та
програма
Ну
колеги, я бачу вас
оплески, я бачу ваші усмішки та обличчя
тепер я бачу людей, які дійсно хочуть
приєднайтеся до цієї дискусії, і ми маємо
є чим пишатися, тому що у нас є
попереду велика подорож
ми маємо великі можливості
за інновації для науковців
до
здійснити це, щоб реалізувати
інновації
потрібно багато компонентів
що дозволить вам
досягти успіху одна річ мати
ідея, але проблема є
Ідея
нічого не коштує, вам потрібно це повідомити
ви повинні підтвердити це
якщо це справді
вимагається
якщо це дійсно потрібно
якщо є люди правильні люди, які
може це реалізувати
і ви повинні повідомити про це
представлені
отримати підтримку, оскільки
одна справа мати ідею інша справа
є
щоб це сталося отримання конкретних
прототипи і
комерціалізація, отримання патентів і
мати про що поговорити
приблизно
є багато кроків до цього
за цим стоїть багато командної роботи
є багато людей, які готові
працювати над реалізацією цих ідей
перевірка ідей
гнучке дизайнерське мислення
через
пандемія та локдауни
ми
дізналися, що пандемія стала нашою
найкращий спритний тренер
незважаючи на їхні обмеження та
звичайно, якщо у вас є належна підтримка, якщо
у вас розумні гроші
підтримується
нашими наставниками нашими партнерами ми можемо
досягнути набагато більшого
це буде щось наше наступне
панель буде присвячена таким чином
до
говорити про
конкретний
кроки в рамках наших зусиль щодо інтеграції
я надаю слово
до
доброго ранку шановні колеги я перепрошую
для
це
реалізувати до прибуття
я б хотів
кажу вам, що міністерство освіти
і наука україни займає необх
кроки для інтеграції
нашу країну в європу
дослідження
область
сьогодні я буду говорити про те, що ми маємо
досягнуто
цього року які
наші плани на найближче майбутнє
що наше
досягнення і
що
які проблеми ми маємо справу
з в уряді і з нашими
європейські колеги
на початку я буду
поділитися a
кілька речей про
бачення
наукові інновації
дослідження є ключовим інструментом для
інтеграція в європейські дослідження
площа і
міністерство та уряд
усвідомлює це, як і президент
ми не можемо цього сказати
насправді у нас немає проблем
деякі, але ми маємо справу з ними
перший
є дослідницька інфраструктура с
котрий
працюють наші українські вчені
по-друге, це недосконалий бюджет
інструменти
підтримки
проектів на національному рівні та
частково на міжнародному рівні
по-третє
це
поки що низький рівень співпраці
українські дослідники галузі та
бізнес
рік маємо
концепція державної програми для
розвиток дослідницьких інфраструктур
на 2021-26 роки
ми вже розробили
проект в
національна програма
і
ми допрацьовуємо з міністром
фінансів україни та я
сподіваюся, що найближчим часом огляд
цієї важливої ​​державної програми буде
подано до уряду
по-друге
цього року
прийнято закон, який сприяє
розвиток наукових парків
це дозволить нам
щоб зменшити
бюрократичне навантаження на дослідження та
навчальних закладів для створення таких
частини і буде
заохочувати ефективних
розвитку
третє цього року
було подано до парламенту
стимулювати
минулого тижня
комітет парламенту з
наукова освіта та інновації
розглянули цей законопроект
були зроблені деякі зауваження
i
сподіваюся, що кінець тут - це майбутнє
комітет буде
зверніться до тих, і це буде
розглянуто парламентом
Об'єднані Нації
цільовий
підтримки країн у їх розвитку
дорожні карти
до реалізації та досягнення
стійкий
цілей у.н
тому я хотів би це знати
наш
велика команда працює над створенням
національний
план відкритої науки відповідний
розроблено проект документа
це завершується і
i
сподіваюся, що на початку наступного року
це
буде опубліковано для
a
громадське обговорення також міністерство
розроблений
принципові поправки до
закон про дослідження і наук
діяльність, пов'язана з відкритою наукою
питань
пов'язані з
діяльність молодих дослідників і
також розвиток досліджень
інфраструктура
я також хотів би це знати
виконано багато роботи
в ЄС
створено проект, який допоможе
нам
продукції для проведення аудиту якості
дослідницької інфраструктури, яка є
в наявності на даний момент в україні і
що було б нам у пригоді
ідентифікувати
в
пріоритети якості для розвитку цього
інфраструктура
як у європейських країнах
давно це зрозумів
що
країна не може побудувати все кожен
країна
вибирає свій пріоритет і входить у
європейський дослідницький простір з тим
пріоритет і це забезпечує
інфраструктури для всіх дослідників
ну ні
тільки в україні скажімо верховний
і
так само є в європейських країнах
маючи ці унікальні дослідження
інфраструктури зроблять це
доступний для наших дослідників і це
проект розпочнеться
наступного року
ми маємо
інформація про перевірені фінанси для цього
і
були обрані експерти та
17-річчя січня буде
представлені
я також можу згадати про
той факт, що протягом
поточний рік
є значний прогрес у
сприяння нац
електронна інформація
система дослідження інформаційної системи
котрий
допомогло б зменшити бюрократичне
тягар
для
пошук інформації про документи та
участь, як ми насправді
розвиток глобальної бази знань
де центральною фігурою буде a
український дослідник і
ви зможете знайти всю інформацію
про ту особу, яка доступна
про гранти і
наукових праць та участь у
події так що
кожен науковець є дослідником
коли подається до
при подачі заяви
для наступних грантів або
або
конкурси
вони він міг швидко
завантажити цю інформацію та для
експертів це буде легко перевірити
достовірність цієї інформації
а тепер про найголовніше
12 жовтня
я думаю, ви чули про це
присвоєна україна
договір про перевищення наступного
рамка
програма горизонт європа тепер проект закону
та ратифікація цього
Угода знаходиться в офісі президента
і я вірю в грудні так і буде
передано на розгляд в
парламент, я і мої колеги
в тому числі
інші міністерства та Кабмін
міністрів україни
пройшли це
важкий шлях і Україна стала
перша країна Східного партнерства
серед країн Східного партнерства
яка підписала цю угоду та
поза членами
Є лише Норвегія та Ісландія, які
були зовсім інші проблеми в термінах
співпраці з
горизонт європи, тому я вважаю, що це було a
фундаментальна робота, яка мала бути
які мають ці конкретні
результат і буде
як результат
українські дослідники будуть
потрапити в цей спільний пул
співпраці з європ
дослідники, і ми хочемо мати
картина, яка у нас була
раніше, коли ми вийшли до попереднього
програму, коли вони не знали, куди
піти куди подати і що і
так
тому ми маємо інформацію
що перші два
проектів на суму 800 000 євро
були обрані для фінансування в
рамки цієї програми, і я вірю
найближчим часом кількість таких
проектів збільшиться
і Україна матиме можливість
матиме експоненціальне зростання
у наступній рамці
запрограмувати те, що ми хочемо зробити
участь українських дослідників
кращої якості та більшого масштабу
Перш за все, ви знаєте, що у нас була мережа
з
національні контактні пункти, які
прооперований
за попередньою рамковою програмою і
намагався
бути
джерело ключової інформації
інформації для всіх дослідників немає
лише дослідники, але підприємці
та організації тощо
поступово ми будемо розвивати нове
нормативні документи
для розвитку цієї мережі у нас є a
мрію створити офіс
програма горизонт європа в україні
і
є підтримка кількох міністерств
тому з цією метою
багато роботи буде виконано і триває
зроблено
запустити національний портал для
горизонт європа
коло повноважень
в даний час
вже вжито заходів і е-е
з наступного року будемо
працювати з цим порталом
тож це ключові повідомлення, які я б хотів
хочу доставити вам
і зараз я прошу вас приєднатися
поширювати інформацію про горизонт
Європа
і це е-е
можливості серед ваших колег
вся суть програми
відкритий для всіх для
українські учасники тому з квіт
травень 2021
і у всіх відкритих колах можна
брати участь
усвідомлюючи, що укр
уряд
заплатить
відповідні внески
відповідні збори наступного року після
повідомлення, і ці проекти будуть
фінансується для українських учасників так
Дякую за увагу
ну я буду
відповісти на всі запитання, якщо такі є
Дякую
директора дирекції досліджень
та інновацій міністерства с
науки і
освіта в україні, а якщо ні
пам'ятайте, залишимо для всіх питань
перерва на каву
так
Подяка міністра освіти і
наука україни за всі кроки ім
приймають до
допомогти інтегруватися
України в дослідження
науковий
області, і ми це відчуваємо
досягнення і ті результати, які
стати нашим
світ
інновації та досягнення, тож давайте
продовжити і далі
тема
ми будемо
обговорити ну
головний
компоненти так
ти знаєш, Адам, і наша наступна сесія
про це я хотів би запросити
центр програмного комітету, який є
зосереджено на перспективних дослідженнях в ан
інноваційний проект
тому в
атомна енергетика та рішення
є представником програми
комітет термоядерного синтезу
синтез
і він представляє ну
Інститут фізики Харпера
технології
так гм
Будь ласка, зверніть увагу на екран
екран uh привітання від
ну кев
в
мій
презентація я буду
Спробуй
дати вам огляд поточного
ситуація і
ну
в
програма для горизонту європа україна
підписали єдину угоду про асоціацію
горизонт в європу і євро артем
Що стосується євроатома, я зосереджусь на двох
області електрона
програма це термоядерна
дослідження як основа зеленої енергії
майбутнього і актуального
в
джерело енергії без ум
ці сфери дуже важливі для
Україна
про термоядерну програму
це інший атом енергії
ну бути
зроблено в рамках консорціуму euro fusion, який
включає 30 бенефіціарів з різних
країни
Великобританія та Швейцарія входять до складу
процес підписання угоди про злиття євро
включає понад 150 афілійованих осіб
члени та національні бенефіціари
закладів дослідження
університети та приватні компанії
Україна була
займається діяльністю так eurofusion
починаючи з 2017 року
і
курс
цього року реалізації програми
горизонт 2020
дуже добре були дуже хороші результати
на даний момент було дано хороший старт
наступний
рамкова програма консорціуму, яку ви бачите
на слайді підготував пропозицію
для
в рамках горизонту в Європі
і ця дослідницька пропозиція була
недавно
схвалений Європейською комісією
а зараз
ми в процесі підписання
грантовий договір на 20
20 25 і це
знаходиться у фіналі
етап підписання це перший
результат участі україни в
обрій європа і
у цьому консорціумі europe fusion за 20
до 21 25
насправді
ми були створені
укр
компонент, який включає
три установи Національної академії ім
наук харків
інститут фізико-фізичних технологій
інститут ядерних досліджень
інститут теоретичних досліджень ім
baccalaureath і наша тригодинна леді
університети
цей каражанський університет
національного університету та нац
політехнічний університет
як
менеджера та підписати підписаний договір
за те, що був таким менеджером для наступного
програма
і ми маємо
право керувати голосуванням
загальні збори, але що найбільше
важливим для наших дослідників є те
українські дослідники матимуть
і вже є і продовжує мати
доступ до європейських експериментальних
такі установки, як фондовий ринок
ccv і стеларатор w7x
і
kfpt також має
потужні дослідницькі засоби, тому я просто
чули плазмові прискорювачі й вони
вміння брати участь у кооперативі
дослідження
я повинен це сказати
ми ласкаво просимо
все
інші партнери з країни, в якій вона може
бути
університет або приватна компанія або a
науково-дослідний інститут
ви знаєте, який виконує a
термоядерні дослідження
реалізується на основі співфінансування
принципи європейської комісії
може здійснювати відшкодування як a
результат за підсумками року тех
кошти витрачаються протягом років на ст
рівень 55 відсотків для
успішної співпраці в
участь в європейському атомі нам потрібна
національний
програми для української складової та
цей факт не рівень дослідження
є основною перешкодою для
збільшення нашої участі в євро
атомні програми, і це вірно в
перше місце для наших науково-дослідних інститутів
закладів і навч
заклади, особливо університети
оскільки
вони мають дослідження
проектів у цій сфері це важливо
важливо, щоб
Міністерство освіти і науки запустило
конкуренція за це
та інші речі, такі як національні
науковий фонд фінансування
установи
на цьому слід чіткіше зосередитися
наші європейські пріоритети
участь, яка буде
допоможіть нам
я не стимулюю нашу участь
хочу сказати, що в деяких він обмежений
особливо у вашому атомі, і це a
приємно знати, що це поєднує
дослідження в освіті та на цьому
слайд ви бачите навчальні заходи
в рамках eurofusion на даний момент немає
три
майор
факторів, тому це злито в європейську мережу
Fusion Education адресація
університет уже бере участь
це і асоціація мережі запобіжників
допомагає студентам стати кращими студентами
подорожувати та брати участь у марці
на зустрічах
і на даний момент у вас є
ну приблизно 60
000 євро за підтримку робочого пакету
навчання та виховання року
злиття тому кожен заклад і
бенефіціар може отримати відшкодування
над цим також є цільовий
коло досліджень
освіту чи гранти, особливо
в європі проводяться спільні заходи для
Наприклад, нещодавно відбулася подія
подія pg
2021 це було 22 листопада
23 що дає змогу нашим аспірантам
щоб тісніше спілкуватися з ними
колеги
в плані нового клубу але є
15 поточних проектів
котрий
продовжувати
на наступному горизонті європа
програма
в
терміни горизонту
За жовтень закрито 16 дзвінків
7 це був крайній термін
і я очікую, що нові проекти з
з'явиться і участь україни
є два відкритих конкурси на подання
це інноваційна ціна для therma
ядерні дослідження і наступний раунд
очікуваний
навесні наступного року як приклад можу
дати вам цей проект, де два
залучаються бенефіціари
на українську і дві
установи партнери та
інститут елементної геохімії і
для інституту фізики і
технології та
до
закінчити свою презентацію тим, що я
почався
у нас нац
точка євроатома, і я говорю
від того
з його приміщень так завдання в
Сенс полягає в тому, щоб спілкуватися з
українських дослідників
а також надавати консультативні послуги та допомогу
їх для підготовки нових проектів ви можете побачити
посилання на веб-сайт для пропозиції
контактний пункт європи україна так
будь-хто може звернутися, буду радий допомогти
ви
для наступного
програма дякую за вашу
[Музика]
національний науковий центр у Харкові
інститут фізики дякую дякую
для цієї інформації, і ми можемо це побачити
успіх був неймовірним
в
ядерна фізика і
захист від радіації
шлях
і ми йдемо далі
у нас сьогодні дуже щільний графік
у нас їх багато
попереду презентації та дискусії
тому українські учасники активні
всі напрямки програми
але
я повинен сказати, що в деяких областях
нам є що покращити
і ми будемо
говорити
про область, на якій зосереджено увагу
підтримка мобільності
і
наукового супроводу від
ЄС та асоційовані країни
розповість вам про це більше
хто працює як національний контакт
точка
так що слово за вами каріна
головний науково-дослідний центр ім
дослідження інтелектуальної власності та
трансфер технологій національної академії ім
науки україни аплодисменти будь ласка добре
слово за вами, дякую
я б хотів
вітаємо всіх учасників і бажаємо
успіхів і співпраці
відтепер у європейській програмі Horizon
і моє завдання тут поговорити про
горизонт першої арійської Європи
відмінна наука
він складається з трьох компонентів
підпрограми Європейська дослідницька рада
Моріс Кордовська q реакції і
дослідницькі інфраструктури
мільярд
[Музика]
25 всього
євро
а це чверть бюджету
виділяється на ці програми і
вони спрямовані на підтримку відмінників
наука що
називається прикордонним дослідженням в
документ і він зосереджується на
ломка дослідження
але є різниця від
горизонт 2020
більше уваги приділяється драйву
ми стоїмо за всіма цими інноваціями
вчені
зосереджено багато зусиль
назустріч
розвитку
створення хороших умов
за довічну працю
це їхні сім'ї
поставлені завдання
що область
і яка унікальна
від іншого
програми
цей компонент
передбачає участь в
окремі науковці
що неможливо для наших
програм, з яких має бути команда
дослідники, але тепер індивідуальні
дослідники отримали підтримку і
ще один унікальний варіант
це підхід знизу вгору
коли дослідник
вміє
до
представити
проекти
самотній тому що
оскільки в інших проектах вони просто
отримати вже
теми тепер справа за науковцями
вибрати
площа
перший - це грант
Європейська дослідницька рада eoc є a
його місія — заохочувати
дослідження найвищої якості в Європі
але
мета реалізувати
ідеї
дослідники
з різних країн немає
обмеження тут
але це має статися в європі
erc був
знайдений в 2007 році
як компонент рамкової програми
і відтоді
його функції все ще існують
це частина зусиль європейської підтримки
для
новаторські дослідження
і еок
підтримує фундаментальну науку
але це поступово змінюється, і ми
розуміти це
вони не просто підтримують фундаментальні
науки, а й прикладної науки і
інновації
там має бути весь комплекс
і результати повинні бути
новаторський не просто
фундаментальна наука, але в
повсякденне життя
як їх оцінюють
оцінюється за одним критерієм
досконалість
весь проект перевірено та
біографію науковців
подання проекту
після отримання вченим фінансування
головний науковий співробітник проекту
може вільно зібрати команду дослідників
і загарбників
реалізувати цей проект
є розпочата консолідована дотація
дотації та передові дотації
вони доступні для більшості
вправний
вчені
і є
енергетичні гранти для групи в
від двох до чотирьох дослідників, які збираються разом
впровадити
гранти на дуже амбітний проект
більш довгостроково орієнтований і, звичайно
вони отримають більше веселого фінансування
друга програма - марі ескудо
кюрі
дію
програма Я національний контактний пункт
для цієї програми у нас було чотири програми
Україна
у нас було чотири точки контакту, можливо, ми будемо
мати більше в майбутньому, але те, що воно є
все про
підтримка
грантова підтримка надається окремим особам
дослідники
для асп
стипендії
до цього у нас були індивідуальні
з ступенем або без нього вони могли
брати участь
як дослідники
і
вони можуть провести це дослідження в
країн ЄС чи третіх
країни, які є європейськими чи глобальними
товариство
щодо інноваційних докторських проектів
мережеве навчання інноваційне навчання
мережі, на якій вони зосереджені
розробка наукових програм
з результатом
досягнення доктора філософії
за
аспірант
студентів
і must-have є
залучення пром
учасників
і
подальший нагляд
проекту інший проект
якими займається msca
є ну
научно-исследовательский обмен дослідницький обмін
це називається кадровими змінами
програма
що зосереджується на реалізації
дослідницькі проекти
використовуючи
короткий термін
мобільність
різні учасники з Європи
країни україна та треті країни
і
це було раніше
міжнародні та міжсекційні
мобільність
у наступній програмі
ми також маємо міждисциплінарну мобільність
якщо є проект у секторі
що дуже важливо, оскільки це
полегшує
вибір консорціуму та
шукати партнерів ще два типи
проектів називається
співзасновництво
на національному міжнародному регіональному
рівні, де ми маємо
грантові програми для аспірантів
студентів
і якщо
цей грант також передбачає певне фінансування
надається до
розширення чисельності
учасників розширення
фінансування
інший тип
раніше називалися вечорами вчених
це коли наукові організації та
вчені мають a
можливість представити свої наук
результати для громадськості
провести кілька майстер-класів
фестивалі наук
події до
робити це для дітей, щоб це могло заохочувати
вибрати науку своєю кар’єрою
ще одна сфера – дослідницька інфраструктура
це сайти, які надають
ресурси та послуги для
дослідницьке співтовариство
і мета цього конкурсу в
Horizon Europe і Horizon 2020
полягає в забезпеченні
розвитку цих інфраструктур
створення великих наукових структур на
глобальний рівень
і
крім наукової діяльності
ці
дослідницькі інфраструктури можуть забезпечити
навчальний
публічні заходи
деякі приклади можуть бути
великий масштаб
обладнання та колекції
архів наукових даних або ін
компоненти
інфраструктури, але вони повинні бути унікальними
і вони повинні бути відкритими
для загального доступу у своїй країні та
інші країни
вимога
частина програми horizon europe
планується фінансування
фінансувати
створення нових
структур на основі європейських наук
установи
а також інтеграція актив
наукових структур у їх глобальному
мережі їх консолідації та
розвиток віртуальн
дослідницькі інфраструктури
так
вітаю всіх з
офіційний запуск програми та я
заохочувати вас до
займатися не тільки в
дії Марії Кюрі
а також отримати гранти від європейських
дослідження
ради
отримувати гранти і займатися своїм
науково-дослідна установа європ
рівень дякую дуже дякую
для техніки
головний науковий співробітник
добре, чувак, це було
пройшло півгодини, а у нас так
багато
ідей так багато областей
отримати
велика дослідницька перспектива та
можливості, тому давайте рухатися без зупинок і
якщо говорити про горизонт європи
програма є
встановити на сім років і можна тільки
уявіть, скільки випробувань буде у нас усіх
обличчя
зміни клімату та
впровадження
штучного інтелекту інтелекту
ідеї
зелена енергія
і
ми поговоримо про ці світові тренди
під час нашої сесії
сергій
НКП на базі Київського політехн
інститут
імені Сікорського Ну Сергія
Шукаєв буде говорити про глобальне
виклики та європейські промислові
конкурентоспроможність
слово за вами
пані та панове
привіт
вітаю
з підписанням
Угоди про асоціацію та давайте
тримаємо кулаки
до
ратифікувати це, щоб це було ратифіковано
і я
працюючи в
київський політехнічний інститут я ncp
для горизонту 2020, і я можу це сказати
ці європейські рамкові програми
унікальне явище
унікальний у фінансуванні
охоплення та рівень міжнар
співробітництва так для
ваші українські вчені, які будуть
які братимуть участь у horizon europe
це не просто можливість знайти
фінансування
для
науково-інноваційні проекти
його
також можливість отримати нові навички та
знання
новий досвід, нові друзі та партнери
і звичайно
продемонструвати досягнення
якщо ми
подивіться на структуру горизонту
Європу я можу порівняти з птахом
що має
два крила
провідний
наука
але він також має великий
пружний корпус
туша, яка тримає все
разом
і це тіло
це другий стовп другої області
по-європейськи глобальні виклики
промислова конкурентоспроможність
є
досягнення цілей
політики ЄС та впровадження
цілі сталого розвитку
з
і це
має 53,5
мільярдів євро, що становить 50 56 від
загальний горизонт європи бюджет
цю програму
ділиться на кластери
це підтримуватиме діяльність суглоба
дослідження
центр новий фінанс
будуть реалізовані інструменти, які є
місії r і i
для європейського союзу
високий рівень
доступна підтримка
він передбачає створення a
консорціум
у складі трьох юридичних осіб від
три різні члени ЄС або асоційовані
країни
його
багатоступінчасті
воно поділяється на
різні кластери
тематичні зони та кожен кластер
розділені на різні області
і потім
пакети
з
створені наші та я дії
наскільки ці шість кластерів
стурбований
друга ключова сфера
сюди відноситься творчість культури здоров'я
та інклюзивне суспільство
цивільна безпека
для суспільства цифрова індустрія та космос
кліматична енергія та мобільність
харчування економікою природних ресурсів
сільське господарство та навколишнє середовище
і якщо говорити про перший кластер
здоров'я
це кластер
з
бюджет 8,5 млрд євро
він передбачає виділення
ресурсів для оздоровлення та оздоровлення
та підтримки благополуччя людей
різного віку
є шість
пункти призначення
які охоплюють різні аспекти
з
трохи загублений у цій презентації
так
я можу
дати вам приклад
про проекти, які є
характеристика
цього кластера
які демонструють
миттєва реакція
ЄС до викликів, які з’являються
наприклад
конкурс, який буде оголошено в
січня наступного року
який буде присвячений боротьбі
проти пандемії
другий кластер
про культуротворчість і
інклюзивне суспільство
з бюджетом
2.28
мільярд
євро
він буде розділений на три
призначення перший пункт призначення
зосереджена на підтримці європ
демократія
і права людини друге
є
підтримає
збереження
культурна спадщина європейська культурна
спадщини в третьому пункті призначення воля
бути зосередженим на
інноваційні дослідження соціальної та
економічні трансформації суспільства
приклад такого
конкуренція буде
в
конкуренція буде яка буде
анонсували, загалом, наступного року
гм
збереження мов, що знаходяться під загрозою зникнення
в Європі
це як приклад кластера
три
громадянська безпека для суспільства з бюджетом
1,6 мільярда
євро
це
кластер має
надати відповідь
або відповідати на ці виклики безпеці
котрий
продовжують відбуватися, проти яких він бореться
тероризм і
вони є прикладом кібербезпеки
такий
змагання
це той, який буде оголошено в червні
у червні наступного року
ефективна боротьба з корупцією
є його темою
називається цифровою індустрією та космосом
з бюджетом по
5,35 млрд євро
цей кластер викликається, щоб дати відповідь
до
такі потреби ЄС, як
бути конкурентоспроможним і надійним
технологія для
розвиток промисловості та
в цій області ми бачимо
зосереджені всі ключові технології
це цифрові і
розвиток промисловості та косм
приклад конкурсу, який буде
буде оголошено вже цього місяця
на якому зосереджена конкуренція
міжнародної підготовки в
напівпровідників
це одна з ключових сфер, яка потребує
який вимагає розвитку в ЄС
звертає на це особливу увагу
кластер номер п'ять - кліматична енергія
і мобільність
в
Ключова ідея цього кластера
боротьба з глобальними змінами клімату
та вдосконалення
управління середовищем, якщо я можу це сказати
так
і звичайно
це трансформація в енергії
сектора та транспорту
зробити їх екологічно чистими
і чистий
тому прикладом конкуренції може бути
під кластером 5 той, який був
анонсовано вже в жовтні цього року
і зосереджено на
рішення
для зберігання теплової енергії
це інноваційна акція
тому передбачається, що ви
повинні вже мати певні технології
доступні для участі
цей конкурс
кластер номер шість, тому вони бюджетують
8,95 млрд євро
є
присвячений їжі від
нашою економікою та природними ресурсами
сільське господарство та навколишнє середовище
без сумніву, ці проблеми
є
насправді
терміновий
не тільки для ЄС, а й для
міжнародна спільнота та україна як
Ну
так
розумне управління
за ресурсами є a
одна з ключових цілей для цього кластера
приклад
з
цей конкурс у цьому кластері
той, який буде оголошено в
лютий наступного року
його навколишнє середовище на інфекційних тварин
хвороби
діяльність спільного дослідницького центру
в рамках
це
спільний дослідницький центр дослідників
повинні виготовляти нові
знання для розробки нових інновацій
інструментів і ідентифік
нові проблеми та поширювати
знань і сприяти досягненню
цілі так для horizon europe і
продовжувати європу
дослідження
у програмі Horizon Europe новий інструмент
виявилося, що це фінансовий інструмент
це
рецесія
інноваційні місії, які
охоплює міжгалузеві міжгалузеві
ну
область його
Є п'ять місій, тому це
зміна клімату пацієнта в тому числі
трансформація суспільства в боротьбі з раком
тому здоров'я та їжа кліматично нейтральні та
розумні міста здорові океани моря прибережні
і внутрішні води
у вересні цього року
змагання вже були
організовано підготовчий перший етап
для тих місійних центрів ми шукатимемо
направити
нові місії, щоб зрозуміти цей інструмент
розробляється, але вони матимуть a
презентація
присвячений місіям так
ми матимемо можливість побачити як
це буде працювати
і
біля
я хотів би закінчити свою презентацію
сказати, що на мій погляд це дуже
важливо поширювати інформацію
про програму
особливо це важливо робити
для молодих дослідників
та аспірантів
так як представник вищого
навчальний заклад
ми будемо ініціювати це в нашому
в університеті і, звичайно, це
дійсно необхідні для таких тих тих
аспіранти до
організовувати спеціальні курси
до
покращити обізнаність про програму горизонту
тому що вони повинні зрозуміти, чи
їхній рівень відповідає тим дослідженням
які зараз актуальні в
на міжнародному рівні так
такий підхід допоможе їм бути більшими
критично ставляться до своїх досліджень, от і все
з мого боку дякую
для інформаційного спілкування
технологій нац.-техн
ун-т україни
київський політехнічний інститут
тому ми можемо побачити, що вони були насправді
облицювання
різні виклики та проблеми, які
потребує звернення до нових методів і
підходи в тому числі
використання в інноваційних
рамки методів і різні інструменти
отже про інновації та інструменти для
підтримка інновацій для проектів і
не тільки буде
говорити з
наш наступний доповідач та Іван Пультіскі
директора Центру інновацій с
дякую за можливість виступити
Україні понад 20 років
участі в
рамкових програм і ми як
організації
почав з п'ятої програми, що було
важливо зараз це
етап важливий, тому що
з
кінець горизонту 2020
і
ця участь у рамкових програмах
починає справляти великий вплив на
українські інновації
хм політика і про що я буду говорити
такі структури європейські інновації
ради це модель взаємодії
наука та інновації є хорошою моделлю
для України, тому я дуже сподіваюся, що в
далі під час наступного раунду ми матимемо a
обговорення, і я розпалю це
обговорення, тому що один із елементів
де ми повинні
візьміть інформацію
діяльність інновацій
гм
рада ну чому це з'явилося
в кінці сьомої рамки
програму європейського союзу, яку ми почали
так багато думати про фінансування
результати дуже хороші, але це не так
реалізовані в економіці і вони
не використовується на благо людей і
ми говоримо про каркас
програми, які ми завжди запитуємо
дослідники, чому ви це робите
дослідження для іншого
сертифікація кар'єра або публікації але
якби ми хотіли отримати державні гроші та
державної підтримки або підтримки в
спільноті, ми повинні продемонструвати, як
ті дослідження
впливає на наше життя, це новий дріт
інноваційної політики, а також ви
хотів
мати конкурентну позицію в
порівняно з США, Китаєм, Кореєю та іншими
активних гравців
на міжнародному рівні
а зараз як бачимо бюджет
для першого
для другого
стовп становить понад 13,5 млрд
європейський інститут
інновації та півмлн
для
європейська інноваційна екосистема та посилання
між різними акторами, тому тими, хто є
зацікавлений в європейському інституті
інноваційні технології
там було два міста
було б найкращим у варшаві для
змагалися
зараз це в будапешті, але їх багато
філії в різних країнах
ну так ми
побачити функцію
європи інноваційна європа так
підтримка стартапів та
знання рішень так, але ну вони є
узгоджуватися з національною політикою
і це буде виклик для epa
ну як наші
національна політика узгоджується з
європейський і як він реалізується
добре мати хороші цілі щодо того, як
реалізувати це так по-європейськи
інноваційна рада була її центром у
початок для підтримки смс
і ми віримо, великий
успіх семи
інструментів, тож у нас було 16 власних проектів
горизонт 2020
перша і друга фази
це
підтримка
було 10 сторінок заявок
для СМС
знизити бар'єр для участі
і знайдіть їх
мати ці проривні інновації
або кардинальних рішень, тому коли ми
говорити про європейські інновації
рада це a
це поєднання
в
Європейський інститут інновацій і
технологія це a
цілий ряд наших інститутів займаються
університети університети в саміті с
kf
в європейській інноваційній екосистемі
на жаль в україні хтось
збиває з пантелику, деякі люди плутають це з
середовище національне середовище якщо
ми говоримо про механізм
фінансування Європейської ради інновацій
ми повинні зосередити увагу на
значні зміни в Європі, так і ми
шукають стартапи про те, як вони
почали, тому вони вирішили заплатити
увагу до цілого
зміна інновацій від ідеї до
впровадження марки на ринку так
вони встановлюють такий інструмент, як eic
pathfinder, ви можете це розвинути
почніть розробляти його та eic
перехід і це взаємодія з
Європейська рада з інновацій в порядку
сприяти
або ту інноваційну прогалину, яку ми маємо
в україні ми не маємо відповідних інструментів
комерціалізувати інновації
вони можуть подати результати
від попереднього
горизонт європа 2020 і ті, що були
виконується в рамках європейської інновації
ради і коли ми спілкувалися
з національною академією наук ім
дослідники кажуть, що вони зробили деякі
дослідити, що з цим робити далі
так що це
рішення, як це зробити і чи можете ви побачити
що це може бути
реалізовано і
привезли на ринок
ти можеш
отримати належне фінансування для створення a
прототип
те, що ви можете продемонструвати
бізнес
а це прискорювач eic
близько до попереднього інструменту sme, де ви
може отримати фінансування для впровадження інновацій
на ринок
є продавці які вже були
ЗАЧИНЕНО
і порівнюється специфіка налаштування
також підкріпити цю програму на 2021 рік
розпочалася Європейська рада з інновацій
в
21 березня програма була
прийнятих було ряд
конкурси тому теми були
визначено, що вони були включені
енергетичний сектор і цифровізація, але
є відкриті теми якщо
ви могли б подати
ідеї для будь-якого сектора, якщо це
інноваційна ідея і зараз
обговорення тривають і що буде
бути в наступному році офіційних немає
програма тут
але є деякі чернетки
обговорено і
що ми
впевнений, що той тренд, який у нас був, буде
це продовжиться і в наступному році
у певних сферах і це передбачають
що будуть їхні перші змагання
для нас почнеться в березні наступного року
для україни завдання проаналізувати що
були подані у 2021 році
які були області і які були
результати і тут ми повинні
створювати історії успіху не лише в
в
рівня міністерства освіти
наука, і це дуже цікаво
механізм подання відрізняється
певні шляхи від
як
заявки подаються до ін
конкурси чи тендери
ніби це партнерство, коли вони оцінюють
це і так далі, щоб не було
стерти час, який ви можете подати лише основний
ідея з парою слайдів або зробити a
відео коротке відео так званий пітч
і
даних, коли ви передаєте перший ініціал
вибір, і ви це помітили
твоя ідея дійсно цікава
ви готуєте повний масштаб
додаток
і
є більше
балів перевірки
щоб було неупереджено те, що цікаво
тут платформа ai, яка в діал
діалог з вами допомагає вам будувати
ця програма, яка спрощує
це для бізнесу, тому що для бізнесу
це досить складний виклик, у нас є практика
ви знаєте, що вони займаються своїм
повсякденні операції, а вони ні
встигнути
заповнити ці заявки, і вони
часто розповідають
ми, що дозволяємо комусь робити це за нас
і ми подамо його, але ЄС
комісія
вимагає від самих підприємств
робити аплікації
коли дивишся на карту
приємно бачити тут україну
як член асоціації, але
це вже відображає це вже це
відбитий термін на карті ух ай і
вони бачать, що Крим є частиною
україна так нічого страшного що є
платформа спільноти, де ви можете отримати
зареєстровані та отримайте багато бізнесу
послуг, для яких це також є проблемою
Україна, щоб побачити, які є послуги
надані для бізнесу та для
що є в україні є
багато речей, які є наближеними
вони доречні або схожі, тому я думаю
встановлення контактів або збіг
виготовлення
події
дуже важливо для цього нам потрібно
зрозуміти основні підходи
ви можете подати свій
запит будь-коли
вашої програми є багато
служби підтримки інноваторів
платформа на основі штучного інтелекту
у горизонті 2020 ви можете подати це
будь-коли
цього разу ти повинен зробити це
тільки після
воно проходить певний рівень
і покращити якість
оцінку ви отримаєте детальну
пояснення до печатки оцінювача
досконалість
це буде доступно за добро
екосистема інновацій додатків
європейська інновація
форум
було запущено
і це а
потрібна стабільна платформа співпраці
до
побудувати тут таку екосистему
і переконайтеся, що ми спілкуємось
і розвивати наш бізнес
у нас перші змагання
де
ми говоримо про
вимога підтримки
підприємці
ці конкурси не є дослідженнями
проектів це координація і
підтримувати зусилля, але ми матимемо багато
аналітики та хорошого матеріалу
Європейський інститут інновацій і
технології
є низка заходів
включаючи стратегію
інноваційна освіта
ми маємо хороші приклади співпраці
ми матимемо в
подія в
січень
з представниками ЕК
і це пов'язано з
різні інші
установи
як Мері Крі
дію
і ми можемо ми зможемо інтегрувати
його і покласти
і вийти на ринок
ми знаємо, що у нас є інновації
хаби хаби в україні і ми повинні
будувати комунікацію з європ
заклади це є хороші
посилання
я можу поділитися, і у нас є
список розсилки у нас є хороші проекти та
сподіваємося, що українці досягнуть
успіху в цій інноваційній сфері
і
співпраця з європейськими інноваціями
рада буде
підтримувати прогрес і розвиток
інновації в україні дякую дякую
ти івонна кочицька
інновації та комунікації
технології
агентство європейських інновацій, тож давайте
рухайся
наша сцена трохи змінилася, це означає, що це так
час для панельної дискусії
обговорення
між
представники влади та
науковцям надаю слово
генеральний директор з інновацій гр
Масалевич і
нашим учасникам так добре
обговорення і слово за вами
твій одяг
так колеги
хотів би
представити нашу
фінальні учасники дискусії так само, як
сказати, що ти
розуміти, що україна
успішна участь у горизонт
європа не просто
історія успіху нашого служіння
в перспективі це
включає зусилля інших міністерств
так
у нас ростіс
загальний
директора координаційної дирекції
міжнародної підтримки в
кабінет міністрів
проекти трансформації міністерства
цифрова трансформація
голова в
[Музика]
відділ цифрових навичок
міністерство цифрової трансформації
у нас також є alex ecole zhuk онлайн
голова
голова наукового комітету
національної ради з питань
розвитку науки і техніки він
приєднається до нас
так само
вітаємо всіх
привіт
ну я б хотів
добре задати вам кілька запитань
перший
як ви думаєте, які кроки
необхідні для підтримки реалізації
з
ці зусилля гм
на урядовому рівні, що я
підходи та методологія
проекти цифрової трансформації
впровадження
створення нашого гарного середовища
для інтервенційних
проекти та їх участь для в
підготовка до участі в
європейський
ну
проекти це міф чи реальність ми будемо
спочатку я хотів би поговорити про це добре
надати слово ростиславу
але перед цим я хотів би це сказати
він наш хороший друг
і за останні пару років ми
співпрацювали
дуже тісно в різних областях
і рос іслав
має
допомагав нам на різних етапах
з підготовкою
цієї угоди, то що ви думаєте
про це добре, дякую, я радий
бути тут, я радий бачити наших колег
онлайн і
тут просто
не треба
закрийте цей слайд
так що ми гм
завжди добре в темі
ну горизонт для мене просто горизонт
це це це просто цілий світ з
цілий ряд можливостей і
я був дуже оптимістичним
весь час
ти мусиш
цілься високо
у нас їх багато
можливості в нашій прямій ставці
підтримує і
підтримує
це
участь України в різних ЄС
програми
включаючи цей
Ну
Україна бере участь у програмі та
сплачує гонорар, потім отримує фінансування і все це
фінансування
отримані україною міжнар
технічної підтримки, він зареєстрований як один
і ці проекти реалізовані
і вони мають особливі
оподаткування
це частина
великий список проектів, які ми повинні зробити
впевнений, що ми слідкуємо за ними
проекти
тому що є інші відділи, які
монітор
політика і ну
виконання плану заходів в
уряд, тому що ми знаємо, що це
про планування це про інше
компоненти цих планів, щоб ми могли
синхронізувати наші зусилля, але
я зайшов занадто далеко з цим я просто буду
повернутися до необхідних кроків
реалізувати
горизонт європа зусилля на
урядовий рівень, я спробую відповісти
ці два ключові питання
ну для мене
потенціал
є
у розвитку потенціалу є важливим і
нам було ще добре
опубліковані графіки про це
університети, що беруть участь у
проекти та
мені дуже подобається ідея, яка у нас є
ці інструменти ми справді здатні
установ, які розуміють, що це
дуже важливо для мене
ми
проаналізували, як ми можемо забезпечити дію
участь тому що
активна участь є одним із ключових
наступний індикатор для нас
для мене особисто
є
кількість контактів
з
потенціал
ну
партії в ЄС і третій показник
збільшення кількості
успішні проекти
і реальні реалізовані проекти та
четвертий показник легко писати важко
реалізувати і деякі люди
зіткнутися з ситуацією, коли вони просто цього не роблять
знати, що робити далі
тому що ти с
ви доклали до цього стільки зусиль і
тоді ти просто не знаєш
з чого почати
коли ти
дуже хочеться конкуренції, яка нам потрібна
щоб переконатися, що кількість
учасників
росте
і ми думаємо
як ми можемо
забезпечити процес відбору
ці нові ініціативи продовжуються
спливти, несподівано з'явитися
і дозволити цій науковій спільноті
брати участь
і ми
говорити про говорили про управління the
важливість
наявність права управління
ці
коридори та вікна для бажаючих
брати участь
з досвіду, який ми маємо
ми повинні були координувати інше
транспортні ініціативи та ми
зрозуміти, наскільки це важливо
до
підтримка
ініціативи інституту і це не просто
питання державної політики це питання
віри в ці проекти
це віра в людей
що ці люди здатні підтримати
нестандартні ініціативи
і підтримувати його зростання іноді людей
не знаю не хочу розвиватись
у нас є багато вчених, яких вони чули
про деякі проекти
так, вони думають, що це добре мати
вони, але це не для нас
тому дуже важливо їх проаналізувати
вузькі місця
і дізнайтеся, чи можливо це на
в
урядовий рівень до
розширити ці
вузькі місця
збільшення кількості потенційних
середовища, які готові до
конкурувати
подати свої
заявки та участь
в
що стосується другого показника
це дуже важливо забезпечити
синергії між укр
учасників і
учасників з інших країн і в
наша робота
ми завжди спілкуємося з іншими країнами ЄС
піднімати питання
з
будучи
не просто наступна стороння країна
тому що деякі
країни ЄС схильні сприймати нас як
країна третього світу, це дуже
для нас важливо будувати наші
співробітництво з іншими країнами і
показати їм наші можливості в різних
сфери бізнесу
міст
молодість
наука
або
державну політику, і для нас ми повинні
шоу
що ми є
здатні підтримувати ці контакти
ситуації, з якими ми стикаємося, ми це бачимо
ЄС має
готові моделі
вони знають один одного по-різному
університети вони знають, що всі
займалися таким чином шведські університети
займаються сільським господарством
швейцарські університети займаються деякими
аерокосмічний
так
вони мають таку мережу і ми
потребую
бути залученим, тому що це щось нове
для нас і для них це важливо
до
розуміти це
українців
здатні вони можуть представити добре
програм, які вони можуть добре реалізувати
проектів і вони мають хороший потенціал
для цих рішень, так що, ага, я
здогадуйтеся, щоб добре загорнути це, є третій
компонент
для нас важливо зберегти
синергія
між різними
області
так що
вчених наукової спільноти, що
горизонт
існує не просто в бульбашці
ми повинні переконатися, що це
горизонтальний
спілкування живе між різними
зацікавлені сторони
я закінчую є
більше компонентів
ланцюжки доданої вартості та
спілкування
щоб
щоб замість створення винаходити
велосипед
ми повинні підтримувати один одного
якщо говорити про проекти
це як дослідницькі проекти з хімії
важливо
щоб підприємства знали про свої
вчених і
переконайтеся, що вони використовують ці результати та
вони вміють спілкуватися і слухають
один одного
запобігати
їх
стають бульбашками
і чим більше спілкування ми забезпечуємо
більше доданої вартості ми отримуємо і тим більше
ці завдання
буде
реалізовано, що це частина цього
ех наукова угода
дякую Рустеслав
[Музика]
я пропоную нам
почати говорити про
найбільш інноваційна сфера
цифровізація
область
добре, я маю інформацію, що ви
фокус на цифровізації в освіті
це вірно
так що тут можна сказати
можливості, які надає горизонт
програма, можливо, пару слів про
ваш проект, тому давайте почнемо з активного
проекти добре, я хотів би запросити всіх
вас
ну піти
і відвідайте
аеропорт
у нас чотири стратегічні цілі, одна з них
є
нам потрібно вчити для
мільйон українців
до
вміти працювати з цифровими інструментами
нам потрібно більше досвіду користувача
і використовуючи
різні навички
і всі програми та проекти
над якими ми працюємо в міністерстві
цифрова трансформація в освіті
вони зосереджені на
легко
ефективний
навчання
ми
зрозуміти в 2019 році, де він був запущений
Люди
дійсно копати
що
процес навчання
спостерігаючи
гм
серйозні та телешоу
тому що навчання
вимагає від нас зусиль
спробуйте запустити проект
де
в
п'ять-сім хвилин ви можете
навчитися чогось
як
використовувати цифровий
підпис як оплачувати рахунки онлайн там
не так багато серйозних, але це добре
ідея, коли у нас є експерти
хто
добре знати тему
і хто вміє організувати різні
процеси в цифровому світі
і ми маємо, назвемо це зіркою
телевізійна чи кінозірка або
рок-зірка
хто може запалити людей
у нас більше 70
такі серії на платформі, і ми
ми переробили нашу платформу
текстовий зміст
з описом процедур, наприклад як
відредагуйте свою фотографію в Photoshop і
подкасти
де
ви можете просто послухати це в
по дорозі на роботу
в громадському транспорті так
щоб ви могли відвідати
проект
цифровий
освіта у нас теж є
різні онлайн-школи для
вчителі
і
школярі
під час пандемії
ми також маємо зусилля офлайн, наприклад
мережа
тисячі концентраторів
де люди можуть
отримати це спочатку
ручний досвід
з
будь-який
будь-який цифровий пристрій
і відповідно
ми
запрошувати людей до співпраці
тому що у нас є багато тем для розгляду
і передати
користувачів
і ми кажемо, що маємо мету
навчання шести мільйонів користувачів, але ми
хочемо тренуватися більше ми маємо більше ніж
мільйон реєстрацій на
цифрова освіта
і онлайн-школи, і я теж
пишаюся тим, що
що ні
цифрова платформа
може похвалитися
70 відсотків
користувачів, які пройшли
результати успішно пройшли перевірку
тому, будь ласка, займайтеся і
можливості величезні, починаючи з
офлайн-центри, які можна розширити
до
досягаючи кожного міста та селища
до покриття
інші теми
і
у нас є 30 цифрових тем
компетенції, тож ласкаво просимо до гм
погляньте на це
максимум чого
хотіли б доповнити
коли я аналізував цю програму, я
зрозумів
яким чином
трансформації та людей, які будуть
подавати заявки на програму
є цілі, які вже були
шарнірний
і була ще одна 100 послуг
онлайн
яким чином
це можна зробити
є ціла система
cdto
це люди заступники міністрів
цифрова трансформація
заступники керівників центрів цифров
перетворення і є цифрові
команди
це лише частина
ті люди
це там центральні органи виконавчої влади
також суспільство або на рівні
обаси і міста там цифрові
проекти, ми повинні зрозуміти, що вони
є
вони складаються з двох частин, тому
по-перше, це дати можливість людям отримати щось
послуги від держави та ін
це інформація, що міститься в
реєстрів та інформаційних систем
більшість і
відсутність більшості цих систем так
зберігається більша частина інформації
на папері або у файлах Excel
те, що там робиться, це технологія
який використовується для всіх проектів для
цифрова трансформація в
країни це чотири кроки, які ви
можна побачити на екрані, це ініціація
тобто проектування
і
впровадження першого з двох кроків ми
маю до вас прохання
так
зараз існує понад 300 цифрових
проекти трансформації
у всіх міністерствах і печах
і ці
ці проекти
здебільшого потребують розвитку, тому
вони потребують аналізу пошуку
подібні
робочі рішення в Європі чи ін
країн і розвиток торів для
ті
проекти, до яких можна приєднатися
під програмою горизонту або
з іншими міністерствами, тому я ні
згадуючи цифрову трансформацію mr
тут тому що це проекти
які впроваджуються у всіх
міністерств і центр
це включає 75 для урядових
тіла
включаючи джерельні комісії міністерств
і так далі
є люди, які
показав вам
заступник
голови або
заступники міністра
тож запрошуємо вас
співпрацювати
Дякую
є програма horizon europe
спеціальний інструмент, створений для співпраці
міністерства
міністерств і європейських дослідж
область
його
Німеччина, тому там є перспективи
співробітництво для центральної виконавчої влади
влади та для дослідників, які
я б запропонував ті інновації
люблю запросити Алекса
ти з нами?
питання, яке ви чули
о обговорення або
ви могли б дати
окрема лекція про horizon europe
тепер я не великий фахівець у горизонті
Європа я буду говорити радше від імені
посади дослідника
що
могли підтримати держави
по відношенню до міжнар
програми, включаючи Horizon Europe i
розділив би його на три
областей першим є
щоб збільшити залученість нашого
дослідники до
європейська діяльність
загалом тому, що це добре відомо
факт, що подання міжнар
додатків створює певний бар’єр для
дослідникам легше знати
бути в зоні комфорту для ведення бізнесу
звичайний і до
подайте деякі заявки на
національному рівні, а не йти
на міжнародному рівні
і часто
Причиною цього є низький рівень
інтеграція та залучення
люди випадково можуть знайти деякі
партнери
і
беруть участь зазвичай ті
які вже розвинулися
або встановлені міжнародні зв'язки
що потрібно зробити в першу чергу, щоб
покращити рівень мобільності
професорсько-викладацький склад
учні більш-менш успішно
здатний подорожувати
але з дослідниками та
професорам це складніше
особливо
коли ми говоримо про
більш тривалі періоди мобільності, як-от
так річні контракти наприклад вони
допоможе встановити
контакти, які перетворюються в суглобові
підприємства
заходи підтримки, які б
забезпечити повноцінну участь
представників України в
європейські структури, як
європейський дослідницький простір це a
давня проблема проблема, що
україна не представлена ​​критично
там, і це зменшує наші можливості
за впливом і заг
обізнаність
і
своєчасно
передача інформації та тенденції для
нашим особам, які приймають рішення, і дослідникам
це також може бути
інформаційна та навчальна підтримка i
зрозуміти, що є a
національна система контактних пунктів
але
я маю на увазі дещо інше не тільки
підтримка в пошуку партнерів або
консультації з деяких загальних питань я
кажучи, що у нас є певна кількість
тепер люди, які мають особистий досвід
в написанні заяв успішно
програми та
успішне управління проектами
якби я міг організувати
такий обмін досвідом
це дуже легко легко для людини, яка
вже подали
програми
дивитися чужу заявку
і подивіться, що є
не вистачає, я можу подивитися на тебе
аплікація з ртуті і
сказати вам, що буде прийнято, що
зауважити та дати вам пораду, що потрібно
має бути покращено, тому така порада
було б корисно і
до
допомогти або вирішити цю перешкоду
іншою сферою участі є a
управління
я теж знаю
осіб, які перемогли в заявках на
горизонт 2020
але які були координаторами
з боку україни і обидва
їм сказали
мене
ніколи знову
застосування, але з точки зору бути a
координатор, тому що якщо ти відповідальний
всього консорціуму це як a
кошмар і є певні
викладені несумісні речі
європейцями порівняно з нашим бюджетом
законодавство, незважаючи на те, що це a
спеціального фонду це результати в цілому
купа проблем так
держава повинна думати про організацію
окремі окремі форми
мати трохи
грантові офіси або деякі спеціальні рахунки
до
дають більше свободи використовувати їх для
наприклад, була вимога, коли
останні 10 відсотків вашого фінансування
отримати тільки після успішного
припинення завершення проекту
і
абоподання
всі звіти про те, де це
територія може взяти десять відсотків так
це повинно
передбачити для цього певний механізм
тому що проблема з'являється
яку важко подолати
тому створення структур
які можна було б пілотувати на
проект хірургії так
досконалість, яка спільно
з Німеччиною ми організовуємо
щоб ми могли пілотувати це на практиці
створення таких структур, які
б
зробити це легше та зробити їх кращими та
до
допомогти людям зрозуміти, чи вони
повинен
мати справу з тими
труднощі в управлінні справами і третє
річ, що називається
інноваційність
проекти
коли ми маємо на увазі не лише фундаментальні
науки, але дещо ближче до
інновацій існує цілий ряд
проблеми
нам потрібно було
стимулювати приватні структури до
мати певні справи з державою
заснований на принципах ppp перед тими
проекти виростають до рівня горизонту
проблема полягає в тому, щоб стимулювати його до цього
рівень так, що
ми починаємо мати їх і іншу руку
ми повинні отримати
державні структури, зацікавлені в
науково-дослідний інститут так університети
зацікавити їх у створенні таких
партнерство з бізнесом, який міг би
перерости пізніше в щось більше і до
мати можливість подавати документи на міжнар
фінансування, тому є ціла маса
проблеми в тому числі
податкові пільги
кому
використання міжнародного досвіду або для
приклад звільнення стартапів від оподаткування
на певний час, щоб від цього
це можна використовувати в критеріях для
оцінка і
буде доступне державне фінансування
стимулювати їх підкорятися
програм або створити щось таке навіть
так, повага до того, чи вони
виграти
грунт чи ні існує цілий ряд
речі, які я міг би сформулювати, але, мабуть, я
закінчу на цьому, дякую, олексію
Дякую
щоб рухатися до
Дослідження та інтеграція в Європі
для спільного створення
інновації та
дослідження майбутнього україни, тому дякую
знову
до нашого
учасників та експертів, тому я запрошую
ви всі прийдете
аж до сцени і
зробити
a
фото
ось і наближається перша частина нашого форуму
кінець
буде
ми запрошуємо всіх
[Музика]
Зроби перерву
і
будь ласка, виходьте на сцену, щоб ми мали
[Музика]
робити
[Оплески]
[Музика]
робити
так
[Музика]
робити
так так
[Музика]
так
мій
[Музика]
робити
так
[Музика]
іноземні з чого почати і ми поговоримо
про перспективу ми будемо говорити
майбутнє, про яке ми будемо говорити
європейські горизонти та перспективи
передбачено програмою, яких у нас багато
цікаве попереду і
наш сьогоднішній спринт буде без зупинок і
принесе багато розуміння
спілкування та дискусії
тому, шановні колеги, ми дамо вам a
кілька секунд
щоб приєднатися до нас
якщо ваші колеги та друзі ні
тут ще
поспішай
і напишіть нам, що ви повернулися
ми готові продовжувати, у нас буде багато
інформації
від наших європейських колег і
українські презентації від стартапів
новаторів і вчених
ми поговоримо про багато цікавого
речі
і найголовніше, що ви можете
взяти його в руки
і ви зможете відчути це
тож продовжимо
будь ласка
займайте свої місця
наступний блок буде присвячено
європейські та національні
засоби підтримки для
дослідження та інновації
оскільки
ми щільно йдемо за графіком, будь ласка
переконайтеся, що ви
не відставати
щоб переконатися, що наші
подія
має хороший баланс для всіх
початок
це відео, створене нашими
європейські колеги
кожен великий проект починається з ідеї
їх втілює в життя наш чудовий
дослідники підприємці та громадяни
разом ми трансформуємо ці ідеї
у нові рішення для відновлення після
глобальна пандемія
і забезпечити зелений
цифровий
здорове і справедливе майбутнє для кожного
з бюджетом понад 95 мільярдів євро
horizon europe нове європейське дослідження
і інноваційна програма буде посилюватися
світове наукове лідерство Європи
чудова наука та прорив
інноваційність
вирішення суспільних проблем, які
найважливіше для вас через наш ЄС
місії
[Музика]
розширення міжнародної співпраці в команді
найкращі таланти в Європі та
поза межами
і створювати нові партнерства між ними
дослідження інновацій та промисловості
надавати рішення безпосередньо вам
десятки тисяч у вас уже є
поділилися своїми поглядами та ідеями
horizon europe наш найамбітніший
європейської програми
Європа сповнена інноваційних ідей
давайте використаємо їх, щоб побудувати зелений цифровий
і здорове майбутнє для кожного
у нас є великі потужні можливості
доступний і він того вартий
до
досвід і
участь у відповідних програмах
наших європейських партнерів
це ті
розповісти
вас про ці ініціативи та
Перший спікер нашої панелі — Марія
ліга
хто буде
говорити про
співпраця
можливості Ласкаво просимо Ласкаво просимо до нашого
етап
ну
Привіт, дякую, що ти прийняв мене, я Марія
озеро, я працюю в загальних місіях і
партнерська служба DG Research and
інноваційність
мені було приємно
вже введено в європ
партнерства минулого та цього року i
детальніше пояснює
які є можливості співпраці
на горизонті європи
гм, у моїй презентації є
в основному чотири квартали, тож перш за все я
я скажу, що трапилося в
минулий рік
я також поговорю з вами, чого очікувати
гм
у наступній робочій програмі
ну третій за участю
можливості і нарешті скажу
ви трохи, що є стратегічним
процес координації партнерства
гм
це слайд, який, мабуть, добре
відомий деяким із вас, я просто хочу
нагадати
тих, хто, можливо, не був тут минулого року
це те, що в horizon europe ми дійсно маємо
зовсім інший і реформований підхід
до партнерства порівняно з горизонтом
2020 рік
з ними більш стратегічним і
орієнтований на вплив
вони більш відкриті та прозорі
від них також очікується
встановити синергію між
самі та з іншими
національні програми та програми ЄС
і ми маємо три прості форми
партнерства
одна – це спільна програма, яка базується на a
Меморандум порозуміння
другий – це співфінансований, який є a
спільна програма з державним фінансуванням
агентства
і третій інституціоналізований
що має свій основний акт
тепер
важливі речі, які відбулися
у минулому році є те, що ми маємо
запустили 11 спільних програм партнерства um
у червні, коли ми підписали меморандум
розуміння протягом rnti днів
ми також запустили європейський максимум
продуктивність обчислень ju в липні
ми також відкрили
а зараз закритий курс пропозицій
для
співфінансований
перший співфінансований європейський
партнерства під
перша робоча програма
ми також створюємо стратегічний
процес координації партнерства
гм і є
пов’язано з розробкою першого
піврічний моніторинговий звіт для
партнерства та останні новини
що
ми запустили 10 інституційних
партнерські відносини
прийняття
основні акти для ст
дев'ять спільних підприємств і рішення
для метрології
просто трохи збільшити
ну
гм, і я щойно сказав, що ми маємо
тепер прийнято єдиний основний акт з чим
гм, наші дев’ять спільних підприємств
встановлено
хм, а один основний акт насправді є a
великі зміни порівняно з минулим у
минулі спільні підприємства мали кожен
їх окрема правова база
але зараз є набагато більше
гармонізація завдяки наявності лише одного
регулювання з деякими загальними положеннями
так що це дійсно має допомогти в цьому
більше працюють спільні підприємства
у більш обтічний спосіб і мають
більше синергії між ними, і, сподіваюся,
також зробить життя учасників
набагато легше
гм і посилання на це ми також надіслали
листи з проханням висунути кандидатури до
державних представницьких груп спільного
підприємства та інше управління
структур, і це, безумовно, також
досягнуто
відповідні українські органи
наступний потім копрограма вони
вже сказали, що ми запустили ну 11
з них гм
цього року в червні
а також їхні дзвінки вже були
включено до програми роботи
і зараз вони працюють
розвиток їх додаткової діяльності
планувати
в рамках партнерського консорціуму
та для співзасновницьких товариств у
Стратегічний план у нас досить великий
кількість товариств 16
гм, і вони в основному в
кластери один і шостий, які я вам покажу
за хвилину структура
і дев'ять
будуть започатковані співфінансовані партнерства
ну з першою роботою horizon europe
програму і наступну ну
seven um буде запущено в наступному
горизонт вашої програми
тут трохи докладніше
ті співфінансовані партнерства, які
ми включили в першу роботу
програма
гм
є три в групі один два
кластер п'ять
три групи шість, а також
інноваційні МСП у третій частині
і в більшості випадків ну дзвінки є
вже закрито
але зеленим ви побачите, що деякі дзвонять
терміни ще не настали
ера систем охорони здоров'я та догляду
для здоров’я та стійкої блакитної економіки
і зараз є також деякі співзасновники
партнерства, які є
запланована на 23 24 програма роботи
їх сім або вісім
вони переважно знаходяться в кластерах один і шостий
гм, чому я кажу, що, можливо, восьмий, тому що для
готовності до пандемії у нього немає
ще не вирішено, чи буде це a
спільним фінансуванням або спільним програмуванням, але іншим чином
ось ви бачите теми
це буде е-е
будь готовий
а також
на кшталт невеликої шкали часу і що таке
Головне повідомлення тут, можливо, для вас
що на початку наступного року ми надішлемо
ну запити на листи зобов’язань до
держав-членів та асоційованих
країн для цих партнерств і
ці листи
може допомогти нам зрозуміти перш за все
які країни в чому зацікавлені
партнерства та на основі
зобов'язань ми матимемо краще
розуміння того, що має бути
профспілкового бюджету розташовані до них
партнерства
і ось огляд усіх
кандидатські партнерства
який вам також корисно мати
в подальшому
всередині цих
тоді червоні коробки
співфінансовані партнерства, які будуть
включено до робочої програми 23 24
а решта також позначено кольором
позначте помаранчевим кольором партнерства установ
гм
спільне програмне партнерство, створене посилання
скупчення чотири і п'ять дюймів
темно-синій і співзасновник
світло-блакитним в гронах один і
шість
[Музика]
потім
так
я прийду
обговорення того, як ви можете
брати участь і які
можливості участі в
партнерства
ось ці партнерства, які є
які потребують участі
країн або які з
країни
ви побачите, що вони значною мірою присутні
кластери один і шість
гм, також є два партнерства
кластер п'ять
а також деякі спільні підприємства, такі як Key
висока продуктивність цифрових технологій
обчислення
глобального партнерства в галузі охорони здоров'я, які також є
ну
разом із країнами
хм а тут важливо що по порядку
гм
для країн, які беруть участь і
їхні бенефіціари також отримають вигоду
вам потрібно надіслати лист-зобов'язання
нам і брати участь
як країна
і фінансування зазвичай обмежується
юридичні особи країн, які є
партнери по товариству
гм
тепер, як я вже сказав вам, є деякі партнерства
вже збираються почати чи є
тільки на етапі підготовки з
угоди про надання гранту готуються
можна приєднатися до цих партнерств
але важливо це вже знати
проведено велику підготовчу роботу
хм, якщо вам цікаво приєднатися
будь ласка, зв'яжіться з координатором цих
партнерства або вони, можливо, вони
знайде спосіб додати вас уже в
угода про грант, якщо її немає, буде
є можливість внести поправку
до договору гранту та пізніше
стадії, але ті партнерства, які знаходяться в
ці червоні коробки вони ті, що
початок в 23 і 24 і
справді заохочую вас заручитися
якщо ви зацікавлені в участі
тому що вони в повній підготовці
фазі, і ви дійсно можете взяти участь
з самого початку ви знайдете
контактні пункти для цих
партнерства на нашому веб-сайті та
також, звичайно, ви можете вказати свій
відсотків після того, як ми надішлемо цей запит
зобов'язання на початку наступного року
і для ключових цифрових технологій
високопродуктивні обчислення та
метрологію, яку ми щойно прийняли
єдиний основний акт, і якщо ви
тоді зацікавлені в участі
вам доведеться надіслати листа від
зобов'язання, яке сповістило б про ваші
участь
тепер мова йде про партнерство, яке
не з країнами, а з
участь промисловості
і тут, як правило, приватні учасники
зазвичай представлені асоціаціями
гм, і в такому випадку справді як можна
ваші організації можуть брати участь
вони приєднуються до асоціацій
ну є пара трійка
партнерства
чиста авіація єдине європейське небо і
європейська залізниця гм де гм члени
дійсно в основному акті перераховані
окремо немає асоціації але
буде відкритий заклик до висловлювання
інтерес для вибору нових членів так
стежити за ними, а також за eit
удари будуть є відкриті виклики
для членів зазвичай
але, звичайно, у всіх цих партнерствах
ваші організації можуть
брати участь у відкритих конкурсах, вони не беруть участі
повинні бути необхідні партнери для того
брати участь у проектах, але будучи
партнерів, яких ви, звичайно, додали
переваги
гм
я бачу свій час
підходить до кінця, ось лише a
корисний огляд, щоб побачити відповідність вимогам
асоційованих країн на форму
партнерство, я вже сказав, що ви можете
стати партнером у будь-якому з
партнерства
а щодо проектів також the
проекти відкриті для участі, але
просимо звернути увагу на співфінансовані та
метрологічне партнерство вашої країни
доведеться брати участь і робити свій внесок
на відповідний дзвінок і в цьому випадку
ваші організації можуть подати заявку на дзвінки
а також
є нова стаття 22.5 в
горизонт регулювання, що також
дозволяє обмежити деякі виклики до
стратегічний
інтереси чи міркування безпеки, так це
також потрібно мати на увазі, але
інакше також дзвінки
проекти відкриті
і нарешті є нове правління
структура для партнерства, тобто
називають процесом стратегічної координації
це в основному мати a
структура для встановлення діалогу
між комісією та країнами
і партнерства щодо того, як ми вибираємо та
впроваджувати партнерства та мати a
стратегічний контроль в цілому
портфель партнерських відносин
і
ми реалізуємо це за допомогою нового
партнерський центр знань, який є
саме цей робочий простір, який я щойно
згадується
це партнерський центр знань
встановлено, воно має свої власні умови
посилання
наразі учасники є членами
штати uh ісландія та норвегія та в черзі
з технічним завданням пов
органи влади країн можуть приєднатися до цього
групи, висловлюючи свою зацікавленість так
те, що група робить, насправді обговорює
вся політика горизонтального партнерства
питання та перевірити, чи нова політика
для партнерства подається заявка
і один із найпомітніших результатів
цей стратегічний процес аудиторії є
піврічний звіт про моніторинг
і ми плануємо перший звіт
до кінця першої чверті 22
де ми будемо показувати um нове
ландшафт партнерства
гм, які в них амбіції
їх базова лінія
а потім наступний звіт буде через два
років і у нас є спеціальна комісія
експертна група також підтримує
складання цього звіту
і, сподіваюся, щойно ми це опублікуємо, так і буде
також дозволяють
ви маєте краще зрозуміти
партнерства, які існують там що
вони прагнуть і просто мають
більш прозорий огляд цього
тому я закінчую тут, я закінчив з 15
хвилин дякую за слухання і
із задоволенням прийму будь-які запитання
дякую за вашу презентацію і ми
буде рухатися далі
тому наступний оратор
зараз ми поговоримо про можливості
співробітництво
можливості
з суглобом
дослідницький центр yelana vids
від спільного дослідницького центру пол
твій
Дякую
доброго дня всім
мене звуть Олена Авідович, офіцер з політики
у спільному ресурсному центрі, і я
дуже щасливий бути тут сьогодні, щоб мати
можливість представити вам спільне
ресурсний центр і співпраця
можливості з нами
кілька вступних слів про суглоб
совместный научно-исследовательский центр спільне дослідження
центр є одним з комісії
генеральних директорів, що це наука
та інформаційна служба комісії
як такий він має місію підтримувати
політики ЄС з незалежними доказами
протягом усього циклу політики
іншими словами, АТ має унікальну роль
на стику науки і
політики
щоб вирішити проблему розсіювання
жодних доказів, необхідних для розробки політики
grc створив і координує ряд
центры знаний центри знань є
утворення, що об’єднують експертів і
знання всередині та за межами
комісія з метою забезпечення в порядку
надати останній статус доказів
необхідні для розробки політики
як ви бачите на слайді
є ряд центрів знань, як
наприклад, щодо міграції та демографії
територіальна політика та просто
нещодавно було запущено три нових
спостереження за біорізноманіттям землі та
рак
з іншого боку інша рука
центри компетенції зосереджені на
аналітичні інструменти, які можна застосувати в
будь-яка сфера політики
як, наприклад, мікроекономічні
центр оцінки або компетенції на
форсайт або центр компетенції або
трансфер технологій
і, нарешті, grc містить 56 унікальних фізичних
об'єкти дослідницької інфраструктури
поширюється на п'ять держав-членів і тут
ви можете побачити приклади кількох із них
як транспортні засоби
так, я сподіваюся, що ви зараз можете побачити слайди
мої вибачення за будь-які незручності i
просто повторю, можливо, останнє
про дослідницьку інфраструктуру джерсі та
тобто grc розміщує 56
унікальна інфраструктура фізичних досліджень
який поширився на п'ять членів
держави, а тут, на слайді, ви можете
див. приклади кількох із них
як лабораторія викидів транспортних засобів
установка для випробувань акумуляторів ядерних
криміналістична лабораторія і так далі і для
мета навчання та потенціал
будівля jrc відкриває свою фіз
дослідницької інфраструктури також до зовнішньої
користувачів, які приходять як з академічних кіл
дослідницьких організацій, а й від
промисловості та дрібно-серед
підприємств
деякі з цих останніх інфраструктур
також відкритий для асоційованих країн
включно з україною і насправді є
наразі п'ять дзвінків
бо ми відкриваємо дзвінки для яких є україна
маю право подати заявку, тому я запрошую вас
перегляньте надане посилання
тут, на слайді
а тепер з того, що ви чули про grc in
ці дві хвилини ви можете ви можете
краще зрозуміти цілі нашого
співпраця з Пасхальним партнерством
а з україною і ціль
головна мета – допомогти зміцнити
дослідження та інноваційні системи до
просувати докази в зовнішній політиці
створення для підтримки розробки політики
передача технологій і, нарешті, до
процвітати
сприяти наближенню до ключа eur
це робиться через різні нитки
роботи в основному через смарт
спеціалізація та трансфер технологій
але також через зелений перехід і
екологічні проблеми
в оновленому порядку денному з лип
2020 або 2021, що встановлює a
спільне бачення майбутнього сх
партнерство існує п'ять довгострокових
цілі та їх кількість на період після 2020 р
результати одного з досліджень і
інноваційні результати
впровадження розумної спеціалізації
стратегії
і розвитку розвитку
дорожні карти трансферу технологій
щодо розумної спеціалізації як
Україна є одним із найважливіших
партнери
для jrc, коли справа доходить до цього
наші колеги, які працюють безпосередньо над smart
спеціалізація представить цю частину
відразу після моєї презентації, тому я
перейти безпосередньо до трансферу технологій
і відомо, що мова про
передача технологій це ноу-хау
важко перенести дослідження
безрезультатно для ринку
з цієї причини спільний дослідницький центр
наших конкурентних центрів компетенції для
трансфер технологій разом з дгр
і я, і інженер проводить a
діагностичний та еталонний аналіз
стан технології передачі
східне партнерство
в тому числі і україна
Основними завданнями дослідження є
описати основні характеристики
зміцнення екосистеми для ідентифікації
слабкі сторони і, нарешті, забезпечити
висновки та рекомендації
кінцевою метою є забезпечення
інформація для доказів для політики
створення та підтримки комерціалізації
результатів досліджень
звіт про цей контрольний показник
аналіз - це мільярдний розвиток
але е-е
але кількість технологій
звіти про країни передачі вже є
підготовлено та опубліковано та для
Україна ви можете знайти звіт на
наступне посилання, надане на
слайд
просто щоб дати тобі просто дати тобі
ідея рекомендацій для україни ім
включити запропоновану законодавчу реформу так
спрощення законодавства
встановлення особливого інтелект
підвищення потенціалу майнового суду
міжнародна підготовка технологій
трансферні контори
підтвердження концепції коштів
інноваційні ваучери податкові пільги
і, нарешті, спілкування з діаспорою
наступні кроки включають визначення та
впровадження національної технології
передати дорожні карти, які будуть зроблені в
наступна правова база сфери
офіси трансферу технологій фінанс
підтримувати співпрацю між
наукові та промислові кола і, нарешті,
ємність billing grc, звичайно, стоїть
готовий підтримати цю акцію та
а також налагоджувати зв’язки між дослідженнями та
інноваційні спільноти в ЄС
і україна
і наостанок кілька слів про
екологічної тематики та т. зв
важкий процес
важкі процеси
це інноваційний процес
розроблений і керований JRC або до
точніше європейський інтегративний
бюро запобігання та контролю забруднення
це частина нашої
дирекція в Севільї в Іспанії
і тому назва
так що це фактично інформація
обмін між зацікавленими сторонами про
що є найкращим із наявних
техніки для інших галузей промисловості
що може допомогти зменшити ефект
вплив промислових викидів на
середовищем, яким є цей обмін інформацією
базується на наукових доказах і приводить
разом усі відповідні зацікавлені сторони
країни-члени ЄС від промисловості від НУО
та різні послуги європ
комісія
основні результати цього
обмін інформацією задокументовано в
у так званому довідковому документі
і одного разу прийняв ці висновки
стають обов'язковими екологічними стандартами
для промисловості
grc створив найкраще з доступних
технічні довідкові документи для 32
навіть промислові сектори ви можете побачити деякі
з них на на на екрані
і такий підхід був
визнаний на міжнародному рівні як a
успішна модель управління для
розвиток і заснування
екологічні стандарти
і такого підходу стає дедалі більше
важливий в україні, оскільки україна має
прагне поступово наблизити її
екологічне законодавство ЄС
законодавство в тому числі промислове
директива щодо викидів і в т.ч
впровадження найкращих доступних
техніка україна також брала участь
в участі в біржах найкращих
практики на
найкращі доступні технології в ЄС
програма зовнішнього середовища
ось кілька посилань, які стосуються цього
тема, і я хотів би подякувати вам за
вашій увазі та передаю слово
моєму колезі, який представить вам
розумна спеціалізація
так
Велике спасибі
дуже дякую олена
я ділюся своїм екраном
сподіваюся, тепер це видно
так, по-перше, я б це зробив
хотів би привітати україну з
мати таке ну важливе і гарне
організований захід
мені дуже приємно брати участь
це
Я працюю зі східним партнерством
країна з масової спеціалізації я
працював з україною
вже чотири чи п'ять років
і це чудово для мене визнати
великий потенціал країни
я буду дуже коротким через
обмежений час, я не можу вдаватися в подробиці
розумна спеціалізація, але я в це вірю
це може бути в курсі
гм і відомий цим гм відзначився
аудиторія заходу
ця маленька перевірка почалася як a
науково-інноваційна політика
для кращого вирівнювання для економічного і
суспільні результати та останнім часом для uh
результати стійкості
по країнах-членах європейської
союз, але він уже застосований
глобально
у європейському сусідстві та розширенні
політики на деяких інших континентах, як
ну ну
в україні у нас є співпраця
працює більше п'яти, щоб більше
ніж чотири роки
uh ми підтримуємо розвиток
регіональний
транспортні стратегії ми вже
провели серію роз’яснювальних заходів
події
у тому числі багато учасників з
на національному та регіональному рівні ми проводимо
дослідження, такі як
картографування економічного та дослідницького потенціалу
деякі інші дослідження знову в межах
регіони, з якими ми працюємо
проведено
майстер-класи, де займаються наші фахівці
безпосередньо з їхніми представниками
передати деякі навички вміти
використовувати їх
на максимізацію розвиваючого офісу
стратегії згодом
ми також залучаємо безпосереднього експерта
підтримка регіонів, які є
розробка стратегій невеликих позицій
з нами і, звичайно, багато мережі
діяльність, яку ми намагаємося подолати
принести різні регіони через наш
територій разом
і з початку цього року
ми також почали працювати з
національного рівня для розумної спеціалізації
що так само стосується
цілі сталого розвитку, і я буду
створіть для нього один короткий слайд
ми раді бачити, що є
прогресування інтересу та прогресування
регіонів, які зараз з нами працюють
розвиток розумної спеціалізації
хм, у нас вже 12 українських регіонів
зареєстровані на нашій платформі smartplatation
ви можете переглянути посилання нижче та
більше регіонів звертаються безпосередньо до нас
або через наших співрозмовників на
на державному рівні для реєстрації
цю платформу та ознайомитися
самі почати процес
розробка стратегій
експертна підтримка була дуже
важливий елемент цільової підтримки
Пряма допомога регентам
розробка стратегій
у нас уже було багато працюючих регіонів
з нами
я не буду згадувати їх, просто буду
коментар до плану на наступний рік
що ми також плануємо мати
принаймні сім регіонів
ще не підтверджено ми повинні
поговорити з міністерствами
і самі регіони але ми
дуже радий продовжити наш прямий
підтримка
для регіонів, що вже було
працюючи з нами раніше та приймаючи
деякі нові регіони з нами і знову все
регіонів, з якими ми працювали
буде працювати, у них є трохи
картографічні дослідження, проведені для кращого
інформовані інновації та дослідження
політики
національний рівень, який є
новий напрямок співпраці з нами
розпочато в 2021 році
ну це так
все досягнення цього буде
бути дорожньою картою для сталого розвитку
цілі як застосувати струм
наука технологія та інновації
потенціал
Україна була прийнята як a
пілотна країна, лише одна країна
який було додано до вже існуючого
пілотні країни
для
міжвідомче завдання об'єднаних націй
команда
сподіваюся, ми зможемо прогресувати наступного року
після вже виконаної вправи на картографування
буття
завершено до підприєм
процес відкриття і, можливо, деякі
а також складання планів дій
і одна з останніх речей, які я б зробив
хочу згадати наш останній звіт
які ми незабаром опублікуємо
сподіваюся, на самому початку
наступного року ми провели широкий і
широке дослідження розумної позиції в isa
країн партнерства та україни
курс є одним із них
для потенціалу на основі знань
співробітництво
дослідження досліджує можливість
науково-технічний
спеціалізація разом у поєднанні
з економічним та інноваційним потенціалом
країни
у мене є лише пара слайдів
продемонструвати, що буде
результати, але, звичайно, повне дослідження
представить методологію
знаходження команд і багато іншого
багато інших аспектів нашого дослідження
ми пропонуємо деяку потенційну науку
і технологічну спеціалізацію ми поєднуємо
це в рамках економічних кластерів с
дещо
економічні та інноваційні сфери
представлені як ні сектори і, сподіваємося,
це може бути корисним не лише для
невеликий розвиток спекуляцій, але для
будь-які інші види політики, які б
покладатися на дослідження та втручання
інноваційний потенціал країни та
тут я веду і закінчую свій бриф
презентація, для якої іноді потрібно зберігати
будь-які запитання, які це було б
від аудиторії
дуже дякую за увагу
говорячи
для доповідачів, які знаходяться в аудиторії
і для тих, хто в Інтернеті буде
збирайте ці запитання так
будь ласка
пишіть свої питання і ми розглянемо
їх до спікерів
рухатися вперед, тому у нас дуже тісно
графік
у нас є багато планувальників презентацій
обговорення попереду
і ми є
отримати багато корисної інформації та
перспективи говорити про
ця тема була інноваційною
торкалися під час нашої попередньої панелі
і я запропонував продовжити інновації
тема і технологія
каркас горизонту європ
в повному стані
європейська інноваційна рада була
запустив наступного спікера
присутній о
що так наступний спікер Ерік Олів'є Пог
квіти євро
це просто
інновації
і це так
унікальне в світі поєднання
комбінування
дослідження нових технологій с
акселератор для стартапів малого та середнього бізнесу
масштабування, і це стало
найбільший венчурний інвестор глибоких технологій у Європі
з бюджетом близько трьох мільярдів
це спеціально для новаторів
ми називаємо це інноватороцентричним
і ми дуже активні
підхід із гнучким фінансуванням
різні способи фінансування МСП та
стартапи
а також ми намагаємося будувати
a
справжня європейська інноваційна екосистема
тому причина, чому ми створили
Європейська рада інновацій
вільні, є три причини
що у нас є проблема продуктивності ми
мати потужну дослідницьку основу та a
сильні дослідження, які не є
певним чином перетворено на інновацію
а по-друге також маємо
особливо в порівнянні зі Сполученими Штатами
відсутність прориву та руйнівності
інноваційність
що може створити нові ринки по всьому світу
і ми також визначаємо дві фінансові прогалини
що ми також називаємо
долини смерті перша
відносно добре відомо, що це перехід
від лабораторії до
підприємство для підприємства
тому ми
ми повинні мати справу з цим
перший розрив і другий
нещодавно виявлений факт
що ми не можемо розширити наш
стартапи та МСП
які є дуже ризикованими
і перетворювати їх у великі й великі
корпорації
також, як ви знаєте, у нас є проблема з
ваша глобальна інноваційна екосистема в
європа дуже роздроблена і нам потрібна
включити всі регіони та всі таланти
особливо жінки
ми маємо цю традиційну фігуру
порівняння венчурного капіталу
інвестиції
між ЄС і Сполученими Штатами і
ти бачиш різницю
в чотири-п'ять разів вище в об'єднаних
державах, ніж у ЄС, що є чимось
це великий недолік для
наші стартапи
тому в результаті ми маємо менше
в європі у нас менше єдинорогів ніж у
Північній Америці і не тільки в Азії
Китай
ну єдиноріг
наше відкликання оцінюється понад 1 мільярд
євро
на ринках
і тому в гонці за технологіями
і з точки зору техніки техн
суверенітет ух ми
ми рушили з позиції
колеги в протягом 20-го
століття
зараз із Сполученими Штатами
америка лідирує з азією і
є частиною ЄС, але питання в тому, чи
ми
хто очолить протягом 20 або 30 років з
нові технології гальмування
тож у нас був пілот протягом двох років
під горизонтом 2020
ми
використав бюджет вільного фронту млрд
і ми представили новинки, які є
змішане фінансування
і, як наслідок, налаштування мікросхеми
фонд
ідея полягає в тому, щоб забезпечити фінансові
фінансові потреби
відчувати фінансові потреби
компаній, які ми підтримуємо
поясню детальніше
ми стикаємося з дуже високим попитом
вже на пілотній фазі
як ви бачите, але це все ще так
зараз із приблизно 800 заявками
отримував щомісяця
під пілот ми передбачили спец
підтримка covet пов'язаних
інновації
за екологічні інновації, і ми
продовження
а також підтримуємо особливо
спортивні жінки-новатори
а також набираємо поступово
керівники програм
вплив вже є
видимі відчутні особливо коли ми
товпляться в uh
інвесторів, тому ми створюємо інвесторів
спільне інвестування з eic у рамках
компаній
і ми також
ми
дивлячись на подальші інвестиції в
компанії, які ми підтримуємо, і для яких
час ми визначили
близько 10 мільярдів подальших дій
інвестиції в наші компанії
ми також записали вже три
єдинороги
і
1891 центрів, які були раніше
підтримується vic і які виросли і
стати великими компаніями
ви бачите, що ми дуже активні
тематики, які є зеленими оленями
цифровий і ельф, включаючи covet
рішення
але ми покриваємо
світовий інноваційний ланцюг
від дослідницьких проектів до ринку
щоб ви могли бачити, що це конвеєр
проривні технології, якими ми володіємо
намагався встановити
ми охоплюємо три основні сфери
тематичні напрямки, а це портфоліо
тепер про наших менеджерів програмних проектів
ми маємо цифровий ліворуч
зверху
ми маємо здоров'я на ельфі вниз і
також дуже важливо
зокрема енергетика
зелений
зелена угода
і під горизонтом європи зараз ми маємо a
нове управління, ми маємо нову правову базу
у нас є плата eic, яка була
призначений зовсім недавно і зустрівся для
перший раз 26 листопада
і незабаром у нас буде президент EIC
щоб головувати на м’ячі, і дошка буде
визначити стратегію, яку ми будемо консультувати щодо роботи
програми щодо реалізації ст
програма
ми зараз
виконавчий орган від комісії
з 1 квітня керувати всіма нашими
діяльність, яка є диверсифікованою
минулого року ми заснували фонд eic
керувати інвестиціями в eic
підтримали компанії, і ми вже
інвестовано в 137
компаній
і, нарешті
спостерігає європейська комісія
діяльність щодо призначення правління
прийняти програму роботи та контролювати
впровадження
це склад нашої нової ради
на наступні два роки uh це складено
з 20 людей дуже хм якщо дуже хм наші
видатний
як новатори дослідники інвестори
або
досвідчений
досвідчених інвесторів
тому повноцінний eic
складається
з
ці різні елементи і те, що є
важливо те, що зараз у нас три
три різні інструменти для покриття
настінний інноваційний ланцюг
вони там на цьому слайді
тому першовідкривач для ранньої стадії
дослідження так trl один два три чотири
ну
консорціуми
і фінансування складається з
підстав до трьох-чотирьох мільйонів
а потім ну
у разі успіху
ми досягли перехідної фази як i
казав тобі
допомагати
ці технології розвиваються з
доказ концепції для підтвердження
його цієї концепції
так це підготувати бізнес і
ринок ну готовність і знову ті
дотації до 2,5 млн
і нарешті, коли ці проекти досягнуть
trl шість я б сказав середнє
у нас є прискорювач
розвивати та розширювати наш
компанія, це стільки бенефіціарів або
інструмент єдиного бенефіціара
він може забезпечити змішане фінансування, яке є
складається з грантів до 2,5 млн. но
також інвестиції в акціонерний капітал до 15 млн
в даний час
ти можеш побачити ну
наші результати за цей 2021 рік
особливо для акселератора зверху
ой, перше обмеження у нас було 800
заявок і нас вибрано 65
компаній, які зараз фінансуються
і другий ми результати
нещодавно доступні ми вибрали
99 компаній, які ви також можете побачити там
процес відбору для слідовода та
перехідна діяльність з
відповідний бюджет праворуч
компанії, які ми підтримуємо
доступ до того, що ми називаємо бізнесом
послуги прискорення, і ви маєте
перелічіть там, зокрема, коучинг і
наставництво
а також корпоративні дні
ну
я знаю що є один українець
компанія, яка була
раніше відібрані під пілот
фаза це називається, якщо я пам'ятаю канали
один
і ну
CEO Five Ones розповість вам більше про
його досвід я думаю пізніше в
вдень і які дозволяють знати, що є
його eic досвід
і наостанок кілька слів про програму
енергії, як ми зараз е-е-е-е
наше портфоліо проектів
у нас уже є чотири керівника програм і
ми набираємо ще шістьох в
наступні тижні та місяці
дякую, вибачте за шум навколо
я і я боюся, що я не зможу
відповісти на будь-які запитання, тому що я не можу
чую тебе
дуже дякую, дякую за це
цінну інформацію, і ми будемо рухатися далі
Ну
ми
вже говорили
один із цих інструментів, який є частиною
програми «Горизонт».
це
у нас є європейські інновації
ради ми багато чули про це і ми
буде
сьогодні дізнайтеся більше про те, як ми можемо
зробити це так, як ми можемо це реалізувати
у нас є багато людей, які є експертами
хто
є досвід роботи з горизонтом
душа користується цим
здатність
обміняємося контактами і разом ми зможемо
насправді
досяжність
великі європейські горизонти, і ми будемо рухатися
і мати відчуття
що
ми вже отримали багато інформації
і є ще більше
так
щоб продовжити, я радий
теперішній Марта Томаселлі наступний
доповідач і наступний
презентація буде
присвячений пріоритетам
можливості так
martha thomaselli слово вам
дякую, дуже дякую за
запрошення та доброго дня до
я дуже радий бути тут і
представити вам трохи більше чого
місії ЄС і чому це
важлива новинка всередині horizon europe
так
перші важливі речі, які потрібно зрозуміти
ось чому багатьом із вас нам потрібна місія
можливо, вже знаєте, що місія
підхід розроблено проф
маріано мацукато, який є лектором у
лондонська школа економіки і
університет в Каліфорнії
є способом досягнення
мета, яка обмежена часом і це
чітко визначені часові рамки та
з дуже чіткою метою
навіщо нам місії саме зараз
напевно, щоб наблизити європу
людей і намагатися змусити людей зрозуміти
що таке європейський союз конкретно
займаючись питаннями, які хвилюють громадян
важіль європейської комісії
пріоритети, щоб лише згадати деякі з них
зелена угода пік дії проти раку
планувати конференцію про майбутнє
Європа підходить для 55
порядок денний та багато іншого, про що я не збираюся
інакше згадка просто стане a
довгий список імен
і вони також прагнуть мати інше
спосіб впливу, і це інший спосіб
представлений наявністю портфоліо
портфельний підхід
а також скориставшись тим фактом
ця місія має допомогти узгодити
програм і політики не тільки в
європейський рівень, але також і національний рівень
так
якщо ми
подивіться ще трохи в історію
європейські місії
у вересні 2020 року
група експертів під назвою Місійні ради
підготували доповіді, запропонувавши п’ять
ці звіти були зонами місії
надані цими експертами високого рівня в
в різних областях і вони
також бачив внесок громадян
з якими консультувалися протягом літа
через онлайн-події
у жовтні 2020 року, коли горизонт європа
стратегічний план був затверджений всередині
стратегічні плани п'ять різних місій
районів було включено один на адаптацію до
рак зміни клімату
океанські моря і води
розумний
розумні кліматично нейтральні та розумні міста
і
здоровий грунт і їжа
з жовтневих місій
розпочав підготовчий етап, під час якого
вони розробили дуже надійну реалізацію
плани ці плани реалізації були
нічого, крім плану дій
що місії протягом усього їхнього життя
буде
досягнуть своїх цілей
які їхні цілі та які
дії, які вони планують, щоб
досягнення цих цілей
були включені деякі початкові дії
перша версія horizon europe
робочу програму, яка була опублікована в червні
і ці дії мали на меті підготувати
основа для запуску
місії потім протягом літа
плани реалізації ум
отримав їх політичну підтримку і
тоді 29 вересня ми мали
офіційне повідомлення від європ
комісії, яка підписала запуск о
п'ять європейських місій
Очевидно, що місії ЄС спрямовані на вирішення одного
двох або багатьох основних суспільних
виклики, з якими стикається європа
момент найважливіші з них
ймовірно, кліматичний виклик і
криза здоров'я
всі місії базуються на дослідженні
і інновація означає, що це
основа, з якої ми починаємо
і через них ми прагнемо вирішити
суспільні виклики та визнати
громадяни з ух
з європою в цілому та місіями
працюватимуть у всіх сферах політики, якими вони були
створено, об’єднавши досвід з
різні поля
включаючи науку, звичайно, залучення
з компаніями, які шукають a
співпраця між приватними і
громадський сектор взаємодіє з місцевими
спільноти інноваційні спільноти
міст і соціального суспільства громадян
товариств і велик
очевидно, як вони працюватимуть
надання впливу через нову роль для
дослідження та інновації, тому що це буде
представляють маршрут, а потім
результати досліджень та інновацій
також потребуватиме підтримки інших
поля
тобто приватний сектор
розгорнути та збільшити результати
регуляторна сфера сфера управління
тому що іноді ми знаємо, що деякі
вузьких місць просто немає
пов'язані з технологіями, але також і з регулюванням
управління системами uh
інфраструктура
проблеми, які нам дійсно потрібні
підхід ва-банк, де всі
різні сектори працюють разом
через спільне випробування
в основному зазначено місією і
очевидно встановлення нового
відносини з громадянами
брав участь, як я вже згадував, у
підготовка звітів ради місії
на яких місіях ЄС
місії засновані, але вони також будуть
бере участь у реалізації в
місій у моніторингу та в
етап реалізації тех
як ви, напевно, знаєте всі місії
є програмою під стовпом 2 горизонту
європі та протягом перших трьох років
оскільки місії підпадають під дію закону
перегляду, який має відбутися у 2023 році
законодавство і до 2023 року вони будуть
користь від 10
із загального бюджету рівня 2 і того
загалом становить близько 1,9 млн
п'ять місій ЄС, які були
виявлені справді є адаптацією до
зміна клімату місія проти раку
місія відновлення наших океанів і морів
місія «кліматично нейтральна та розумна».
міст і місії щодо земельної угоди для
Європа
просто щоб дати вам короткий огляд
всі п'ять я збираюся пробігти через усіх
основні цілі uh у презентації
ви знайдете серію qr-коду, який
перенаправить вас до документів
плани реалізації, які окреслюють більше
в деталях, яка мета і
мета кожної місії
тому я почну з адаптації
зміна клімату головна мета цього
Місія полягає в тому, щоб принаймні підтримувати
150 європейських регіонів і спільнот
стати стійкими до клімату до 2030 року.
це означає
підготовка та планування з тими
регіонів для стійкості до клімату
прискорити трансформацію, але також
щоб продемонструвати, що це системно
трансформація майбутнього клімату
стійкість застосовна
і доступні для спільного використання, тому вони планують
мати 75 масштабних демонстрацій
ну це покаже системність
трансформація до кліматичної стійкості
по європейських регіонах і
спільноти
місія проти раку спрямована на покращення
життя 3 мільйонів людей до 2030 року
і це буде зроблено шляхом профілактики
лікування, а для хворих на рак – ні
тільки для самого пацієнта, але також
їхні сім’ї, і це має на меті
мають довший термін служби та кращу якість
життя
це базується на чотирьох основних um
першим є покращення
розуміння раку до
розширити профілактику та покращити
профілактика, включаючи раннє виявлення
і методи скринінгу оптимізують
діагностика, лікування та підтримка
якість життя, без якої вона обходиться
кажучи, що дослідження та політика
розвитку в рамках цієї місії буде
підтримувати європейців
в європі план прискорення раку
місія відновлення наших морів і
води
на 2030 рік
має на меті захистити та відновити як
морські та прісноводні екосистеми
біорізноманіття, тому ми не просто говоримо
про моря, а також про річкові озера і все інше
частина внутрішніх вод, яку ви можете
подумайте про запобігання та усунення забруднення
з наших океанів і вод і
напевно також зробити більш стійким
блакитна економіка, яка має бути вуглецевою
нейтральні та кругові, наскільки це можливо
кліматично нейтральні та розумні міста
має на меті доставити принаймні 100 нейтральних і
розумні європейські міста до 2030 року та ін
в якості
демонстраційні та інноваційні центри
дозволити іншим містам слідувати за ними
таким же шляхом до 2015 року.
деякі з головних цілей - зробити внесок
до мети європейської зеленої угоди
зменшити викиди парникових газів на 55
відсотків до 2030 року
таким чином стаючи лідерами в кліматі та
цифрові інновації
очевидно, маючи
нейтральні та розумні міста також принесуть
величезні додаткові вигоди для своїх громадян
тобто менші рахунки за електроенергію, чистіше повітря
безпечніше середовище, де ви можете ходити та
велосипед і, безумовно, витрачати менше часу
в трафіку
останньою, але не менш важливою є місія на
ґрунт будувати для Європи
що має на меті створити цю сотню життя
лабораторії та маяки, які приведуть до
перехід до здорових ґрунтів до 2030 року.
Метою цієї місії є
захистити та відновити ґрунти в Європі та
поза межами Європи
і вони дійсно зосереджені на
спільнот і зацікавлених сторін
центром інноваційного процесу до
створити знання та рішення, які б
працювати в реальних умовах, тому що ми
дуже добре усвідомлюють, що один ніхто не розмір
підійде всім
і, нарешті, діяти разом, щоб
майбутнє покоління матиме чистішого
більш продуктивний і стійкий ґрунт
для виробництва харчових продуктів, але в цілому
для
люди за природу та клімат в
загальний
тому ми зараз у
етап реалізації місій
були офіційно запущені на
29 вересня
ми зараз працюємо над оновленням
для
робоча програма 2021, яка буде
опубліковано до кінця року
а потім буде другий
поправка, що грішно бути
випущений навесні 2022 року
матиме більше досліджень та інновацій
та інноваційні дії
тож як взяти участь у місіях
очевидно, що плани реалізації
я згадав у презентації встановити
підстави, якими будуть місії
використовуйте qr-код і перегляньте наш
веб-сайт, якщо ви хочете знати більше
в частині дзвінків вже є
деякі можливості вже були
опубліковано, як я вже згадував, у червні 2021 року в
оновлення 2021 року буде
опубліковано до кінця ст
року ви побачите більшу суму
науково-інноваційної інновації
дії і навіть більше прийде в
ми також оновлюємо робочу програму на 2022 рік
намагаючись організувати місію ЄС у
днів, які відбудуться в січні
і будь-які новини з цього питання, будь ласка
слідкуйте за нашим веб-сайтом, дякую
дуже про вашу увагу, я сподіваюся на це
Презентація була корисною для всіх вас
велике спасибі за це корисне uh
презентація з великою кількістю
корисні поради
і ми так багато говоримо про горизонт
європейська програма, але якщо я не помиляюся
на додаток до цієї програми і це
12 жовтня україна стала
асоціації асоційованого члена в цьому
програма ми також
приєднався до додаткової програми
горизонт європа що це і що таке
можливості
наступного спікера ми називаємо клавішею bins
до
поговорити один з одним і подивитися, що є
працює що ні
як справи
пані та панове, це приємно
мені представити цю програму
єдина проблема, проблема, яку я завжди маю
з презентаціями в україні я не
знати, якою мовою
говорити, я намагався
спробуйте перейти з української на англійську
де завгодно
необхідно, і я сподіваюся, що цього не буде
проблема
презентація має величезний розмір
i
я спробую зупинитися лише на більш детальному
важливі моменти, а решта є
додаток до презентації, я сподіваюся
будуть розподілені між учасниками
так
перш за все те, що ми є
чому існує європа і горизонт європа
а як горизонт
євро атом європа 2025 проблема узгоджена
з основними пріоритетами комісії
в основному, наскільки я сподіваюся, що ви
вже знаю
одним із головних пріоритетів в
комісія чудес насправді
щоб повернутися до карбонізації в
більш здорова планета, і є деякі
kpis і
головний з них це
до 2030 року досягти uh
скорочення викидів парникових газів на 55
порівняно з 1990 роком і до 2050 року в Європі
має бути
перший у світі природний клімат
континент і, звичайно, євроатом має
відігравати важливу роль
а також просто щоб пояснити вам, чому це так
горизонт в Європі, а потім є
окремої програми uratum є дві
різні договори, які насправді
керуючий
життя європейського союзу головний
це
договір про функції європейського союзу
воно керує всім, включаючи велике
горизонт ух
європейська програма, тоді як є друга
договір, який все ще недоторканий, який є
уратний договір і, отже, наша програма
є доповненням до
горизонт євро проблема ви бачите
структуру на вашому екрані прямо зараз і
ось з чим ми маємо справу
ефективний із злиттям, і ми також робимо це
деякі прямі дослідження в наших інститутах
нашого спільного дослідницького центру
Звичайно, ви не можете порівнювати бюджет
в цілому
горизонт європа це в кілька разів десятки
разів вище, ніж у нас, але ми також маємо
сказати в
загальна картина дослідження
гаразд, тепер я хочу пояснити вам
основний
головний
тому у мене є деякі проблеми з підключенням
це нормально?
чи можу я продовжити, так, так, тепер я йду
говорити про головне
аспекти підготовки до європейської рецесії
програма і знову, як я вже згадував раніше
оскільки ми додаток, ми окремі
програма з окремою комісією
рішення рішення ради ось чому
ми маємо п’ятирічний термін, тоді як a
велика програма розрахована на сім років
зазвичай тоді наша програма розширюється на
ще два роки, щоб відповідати семи
років uh період
атом євро
програми horizon europe у цьому
зокрема
справа
так наш
основні цілі визначені положенням
за європейським договором і
це фактично продовжити дослідження та
навчальна діяльність u намагається підтримати
ну підтримувати найвищий можливий
стандарти
стандарти безпеки стандарти безпеки
ядерні технології
в
нова програма Європа 2021-25
є деякі нові акценти переважно ми
намагаються рухатися
тільки з чистого
застосування влади до деяких
медичне застосування, наприклад
невладного застосування фінанс
радіації також ми намагаємося сприяти a
певне партнерство з іншими сферами
горизонт європа наприклад
європейський план проти раку
ми також намагаємося розвиватися далі
соціально-економічні аспекти ядерної
енергія і так далі
є також одна принципова новинка для
всі молоді дослідники молоді постдоки
від
2020 вони також можуть подати заявку
марі кюрі
стипендії стипендії
в області уратуму перед тим це
не було можливо тепер це можливо
це наше
основний
бюджет на наступні п'ять років, як ви
дивіться, це не так багато, це 1,4 мільярда
грубо і розділити між злиттям
який йде в основному через єврофьюжн
європейського партнерства є 266
мільйони на рибальські дзвінки, які будуть
принести вам приблизно для
55 мільйонів років на рік і 532
мільйон для
безпосереднє дослідження по
спільний дослідницький центр
знову ж таки вони є нашими головними пріоритетами
я б сказав, що ми досить стандартні
мати справу з a
ядерна безпека
Я отримав інформацію, це лише моя перша інформація
сайт, і я не знаю чому
тому що я намагаюся пройти
всі слайди
зараз я на слайдах 10 чи можливо це
з вашого боку до
показати слайди
вибачте за проблему
добре, я спробую ще раз
інакше ти просто послухаєш мене, але
не буде
Гаразд
немає
так
і кожна з них відкриває нові горизонти
Гаразд
тож мені шкода за це маленьке е-е
проблема але тепер здається що все
працює
ну
ми підходимо до головного
так
Гаразд
до основної частини презентації
він знову зупинився, я ні
зрозуміти, чому це проблема
ще раз вибачте за технічну проблему
у будь-якому випадку я продовжу свою презентацію
[Музика]
основні моменти моєї презентації правильно
зараз це хоча
ми щойно розпочали дзвінок
у вересні знову маємо два роки
дзвінки
і
не тільки двомовний
дворічна робоча програма, але також
кут за річною причиною, яка є a
відмінність від
інша частина горизонту європа, тому ми
мати один дзвінок протягом двох років і для
цілі поділу
110 мільйонів за такий дзвінок у нас щойно був
дзвінок
в
закриття у вересні, і ми зараз
оцінюючи його
і, здається, такі є
українські учасники в пропозиціях що
буде результатом, до якого ми не готові
доставити його вам, але
всі заявники будуть проінформовані
до 15 лютого наступного року вони
знатиме, чи це успішно чи
ні
наступний дзвінок буде
програма роботи
2023 2024 рік
і а
попередній розклад для цього виклику
Програма роботи буде прийнята
швидше за все до кінця наступного року
або починаючи з 2023 року, тоді дзвінок буде
бути запущеним
ну
найімовірніше у травні 2023 року з a
кінцевий термін 23 вересня, а потім
оцінки будуть проведені в
осінь і
ми очікуємо, що насправді наступного разу
будуть підписані контракти на поділ
виклик
в
[Музика]
Весна травень 2024 року
це для злиття для злиття частини
дослідження організовано інакше
цього року у нас був особливий виклик
раніше за так звану відмову від європейців
партнерство
його було запущено, це було успішно
оцінено та відповідно до інформації
доступний для мене
йдеться лише про те, щоб підписати грант
договір для
євро фьюжн і знову по
цінність інформації українські партнери
має бути в змозі отримати фінансування
з цього 2020 року
ще раз мені дуже шкода
технічні проблеми вчора все
працював ідеально сьогодні є деякі
деякі деякі назад
все одно
українською якщо є питання
про нашу програму
будь ласка, зверніться до них, якщо їх немає
запитання, це означає дві речі
все зрозуміло або нічого
зрозумів, дякую за ваше
комплексне представлення та
на щастя, ми встигаємо вчасно
[Музика]
я впевнений, що їх багато
запитання
серед аудиторії, тож давайте їх зберемо
і
передати їх спікеру, а також
запит
доповідачам, тому ваші презентації
дуже
цікаво але
вони дуже стискали вчасно, тому будь ласка
стежити за часом і все
запитання
я сподіваюся, що буде багато і це
факт
ці питання будуть адресовані в
колонки і
також матимемо
перерва на каву та спілкування
здатний говорити, щоб поговорити з тими
доповідачів, які знаходяться в аудиторії
[Музика]
серед наших учасників є такі
які були дуже досвідченими
в
беручи участь у
програми Horizon, тому, будь ласка, поговоріть з ними
і
обмін інформацією це дуже
повсякденна інформація для мене та мене
хотів би
зосередити увагу ще на одному
аспект цькування європи
забезпечення відкритості
даних досліджень і відкритої науки так
так
у нас буде презентація
Олександр
хто буде
говорити про це
тому підлога є
твоя
доброго дня шановні колеги можна
Почуй мене
так, я сподіваюся, що ти зможеш
і дякую, що прийняли мене
мене звуть олександр вераском і я буду
розповім про співпрацю
можливості під відкритим дослідженням
ваша платформа
ой сьогодні ми дві голови пов'язані
професор вільної техніки нац
університету та член генеральної ради
євродок
яка є Європейською радою
докторантів і мол
дослідники
ibraduk — міжнародна федерація
з 28 національних організацій у 26
різні країни європи з
з португалії в азербайджан, щоб ви могли
уявіть, що це велика мережа
eurodoc є некомерційною організацією
базується в Брюсселі
яка розробляє та інформує політику та
Україна була повноправним членом
євродок з 2014 року.
eurolog має кілька напрямків і сьогодні
одним із головних напрямків Eurodoc є
відкрита наука
загалом ще є
дискусії щодо визначення
відкрита наука, але загалом відкрита наука
це підхід до наукового процесу
що фокусується на поширенні знань
відверто правий
а відкрита наука не схожа на єдину
термін але
радше загальний термін для
набір різноманітних відкритих практик, таких як
відкритий доступ відкриті дані відкриті відтворювані
дослідження
відкрити рецензування та багато інших
відкрита наука лежить в основі
програми horizon europe, як було зазначено
комісарами і
такі інструменти, як
європейська хмара відкритої науки та
в
націлені на відкриту безпечну платформу
при включенні
фактично відкриті наукові практики
в
все
проекти horizon europe
тому, як я вже сказав, євродок дуже багато
віддані відкритій науці
багато прикладів цього, наприклад, тут
внесок відкритої науки ЮНЕСКО
рекомендації
ви посли науки Корбіна
програму та багато інших і не довго
тому євродоктор став експертним партнером
у відкритій безстатевій платформі так
дозвольте мені розповісти вам трохи про
ця платформа
відкрита безстатева європа або орі
це інноваційна видавнича платформа
запущений у березні цього року f-1000
у співпраці з європ
комісія після держзакупівлі
процес
платформа має на меті запропонувати бенефіціарам
горизонт 2020 і горизонт європа
і легка висока якість
коли ви спливаєте, щоб опублікувати їх
дослідження безкоштовно і в повному обсязі
відповідність вимогам Європейської комісії
політики відкритого доступу
гм
зараз orem опублікував понад 100 статей
з більш ніж 30 минулих рецензій
вже правильно
тому європейська комісія хоче керувати
шлях у просуванні відкритої науки та
має ряд вимог до
платформа
гм
тому платина повинна дотримуватися
відкрита рецензія
негайна публікація
показники на рівні статті
повна прозорість або політики та комісії
opensecure працює на минулому
модель рецензування публікації
публікація цього означає, що документи є
опубліковано у відкритому доступі з doi's as
препринти, поки платформа несе
з процесу експертної оцінки, що дозволяє
дуже швидка публікація та публічний доступ
до роботи
як тільки документ вважається прийнятим
рецензування, його буде надіслано до індексів
і сховища
так
гм
що це означає на практиці гм
платформа ori
має шість основних областей um
фокусу, скажімо, правильного та такого відкритого
методи та інші відкриті методи дозволяють
іншим іншим дослідникам знати точно
як вони можуть проводити конкретні експерименти
самі, щоб вони все знали
процеси
відкритий код означає, що будь-який вихідний код
опубліковано в результаті дослідження
поряд з паперами разом з відкритим
дані і це також
забезпечує відтворюваність досліджень
виходи
відкритий доступ
звичайно, ви всі це знаєте
тепер
не вся наукова література є публічною
доступний і прихований за
заробітна плата на жаль
чесно кажучи, це дуже дивно
ситуації
в зоні всесвітньої павутини
і технології 21 століття так
політики відкритого доступу повинні робити
щось із цим означає відкрита освіта
інструменти та ресурси, необхідні для навчання
насправді
такі як відкриті підручники відкрито
доступна та відкрита експертна оцінка
це дуже важливий процес, і я буду
докладніше про це
тож чому відкрите дослідження
є чотири ключові принципи
прозорість дозволяє кожному
розуміти, як усе відбувається на
всі етапи, тому всі етапи відкриті правильно
звітність
гм
гарантує, що це легко
перевірити
усі подані результати
і публікація дослідницьких даних і коду
поряд з паперами дозволяє це правильно
гм
справедливість
бути відкритим
дозволяє людям побачити повну картину
наприклад, якщо ви отримали відмову
після подвійного сліпого
процес рецензування, який ви часто не виконуєте
знати всі причини цього і ти
не в змозі відповідним чином реагувати на це і
дуже важливо розвивати давайте
скажімо, поле для чесної гри
де всім все зрозуміло
грати гравців для всіх зацікавлених сторін і
якщо ти все знаєш
я думаю, що набагато легше довіряти
тому відкриті принципи дослідження
я справді підтримую ідею того, що є
опублікованому довіряють дослідники
суспільства політиками
процес рецензування прямо сьогодні peer
процес перевірки
є
мабуть, найбільш прийнятний спосіб
підтвердити частину дослідження
однак скажімо так
якщо було розпочато рецензування
ні
добре, 50 років тому, але в районі
Інтернет, я майже впевнений
це не працювало б так, як зараз
е-е, погляд колег все ще приймається як a
стандарт золотої зірки для науковців
перевірка але
на даний момент, мабуть, ні
і багато
великі видавці, такі як природа
говорити про це відкрито
яка проблема з експертною оцінкою
найбільша проблема з експертною оцінкою
можливо
що
це не
чиста наука, це мистецтво
це думки людей про певну роботу
це приносить рівень суб'єктивності
тому що в основі
не на структурованому процесі, а на
індивідуальні думки
про якусь роботу
гм
ось чому
різні помилки і навіть зловживання є
можливо
через високу конкуренцію в академічному середовищі
через це
це не
дуже легко довіряти
процес рецензування
якщо він не відкритий
і насправді відкривається
процес рецензування може призвести до
підвищення довіри до всієї системи та
привести до спілкування між безпосередніми
спілкування між усіма зацікавленими сторонами
автори рецензенти редактори і
не
можливо, орієнтований на відмову або
прийняття але
щоб покращити результати досліджень
правильно
тому ми трохи відходимо від
поняття чогось опублікованого і
стабільний термодинамічний
спосіб налаштування паперу, коли
ВІДЧИНЕНО
відгуки і навіть коментарі
додати до паперу і зробити його кращим
кожного разу
Отже, що таке відкрита експертна перевірка
чесно кажучи, це також дуже
складна річ і їх багато
різні визначення цього але
ну відкрито
досліджуйте свою платформу
вказує на три основні аспекти відкритого
експертна оцінка, яка є відкритою ідентичністю відкритою
доповіді та відкрита участь відкрита
ідентичності означає, що
все
учасники процесу знають кожного
інші, щоб автори знали своїх рецензентів
а глядачі знають усіх авторів
відкритий квітень означає, що записи перегляду є
опубліковано разом із документом і це
дуже важливо, особливо для ранніх
кар’єрних дослідників, коли вони зможуть бачити все
процес вони можуть бачити всі
звіти про попередній перегляд, і вони можуть дізнатися
з цього відкритого процесу рецензування
служить інструментом колективу
наставництво для дослідників на початку кар’єри
студенти аспіранти
відкрита участь означає, що
чому громада може бути залучена до
процес перегляду та
дослідники, які не беруть безпосередньої участі як
автори або рецензенти можуть коментувати можуть
пропонувати та вдосконалювати результати дослідження
тому open prvo має багато переваг для
авторів і читачів, а також для
рецензенти
насправді
для також
це дійсно робить
дозволяє зробити результати дослідження
краще правильно
і гм
огляди стали більш конструктивними
тактовний
гм
як я вже сказав, опубліковані звіти можуть
бути прикладом для дослідників на початку кар’єри
для молодших дослідників
і для рецензентів це теж дуже
важливо тому що
рецензування
дослідницькі роботи Результати дослідження - це a
праця це важка праця
дуже часто
гм
не винагороджено належним чином
тільки в Україні, але й у всьому світі
і в цьому випадку
ну
open uh звіти можна розглядати як відкриті
з паперами можна поводитись, скажімо так
результат дослідження та додати до
репутація дослідника і до
публічний профіль дослідника
так
це спосіб визнання однолітків
рецензенти
гаразд, скажімо, у нас є все
технологія чи зможемо ми почати
процес рецензування негайно
можливо, не так, як професор Байрон Бондс
gopher Foundation сказав кілька тижнів тому
на конференції в Празі
Дослідницька культура не є вузьким місцем
технології, щоб ми могли мати максимум
передові технології, але якби ми цього не зробили
будувати культуру дослідницької культури
яка орієнтована на відкритість
до відкритої участі це буде
майже неможливо продовжити
тож дозвольте мені сказати це
звичайно ми сьогодні говоримо про
програма «Горизонт», але не давайте
забудьте про інші інструменти
скажімо, нарощування потенціалу та
особливо в галузі вищ
освіти і дозвольте мені просто
ну покажи тобі нашу
оптимальний проект, який означає відкритий
практикує прозорість і чесність для
сучасної академії та головною метою цього
проект відкриває науку
практики в україні, тому ми починаємо
будувати цю культуру
котрий
допоможе дослідникам прийняти відкритий
практики
в більше
скажімо
простіше правого і
дійсно допомагають
до
інтегрувати українську дослідницьку систему в
європейський
так
це майже все з мого сайту
ну дякую за увагу ну якщо
у вас є запитання щодо
ВІДЧИНЕНО
коротка платформа я хочу
співпрацювати дізнатися більше про eurodoc
оптимальний проект, який ми вітаємо
щоб подзвонити мені напишіть мені в будь-який месенджер або
напишіть мені електронний лист, дуже дякую за
мати мене сьогодні і
якщо у вас є запитання, ви найбільше
Ласкаво просимо до
гм
запитати їх
велике спасибі за ваші
презентація можливостей, які
ви представили
ми обов’язково використаємо їх
можливостей і, звичайно, у вас є
питання, будь ласка
запитайте їх у всіх доповідачів
і
після попередньої панелі ви можете мати a
відчуття, що європейські інструменти підтримки є
єдина яка працює крім держави
дуже піклується і переконайтеся в цьому
розробляються інноваційні технології
в україні і далі
панель буде присвячена інструментам
це покаже вам, що відбувається
в україні як завезеш
організації, що вони роблять, щоб залучити
цю підтримку, і ми почнемо з
презентація держ
фонд
тобто надання фінансування для підтримки
українська
розвитку в дослідженні
також фундамент був
uh, створений у 2014 році, він показує хороші результати
підтримуючи наших науковців
Надаю слово керівнику
директора
національна наукова фундація україни
ольга поліцька
ласкаво просимо
привіт шановні колеги
ну по-перше я хотів би
con вітаю вас із цим горизонтом
День запуску в Європі, звичайно, це a
день, якого ми будемо чекати
і
запрошення національного дослідження
заснування укр
означає, що ми нова установа, але
у нас є кілька історій успіху
ми будемо
переконайтеся, що
ви
знаю про них, я виконавчий директор
з
національної наукової фундації ім
Україна
насправді він був створений у 2018 році, але це
почався
фактично працювати в 2020 році, тому що наші
перший
конкурси
для
в
дослідно-конструкторські проекти
вони почали
півтора роки тому ми держава
бюджетна установа і ми як а
результат реформ
і стратегічний
поступ укр.наук
громада
на захід
стандарти грантової підтримки
оцінки проекту та проект
впровадження
і ми були створені як механізм
спеціальний механізм
створені державою
для фінансування кращих наук
науково-дослідні проекти на основі їх якості
і ця якість є
оцінили під час конкурсу, тому ми
надати таку велику підтримку
ми були засновані на принципах конкуренції
створений кабінетом міністрів р
україна як а
в незалежній установі
і ми вже другий рік
існують
але
Я хотів би зупинитися лише на головному
перш за все принципи нашої роботи
підтримуємо найкращих
інтелектуальний потенціал
серед усіх
вчених, і ми зосереджуємося особливо на
підтримка молодих учених
Ну
мені не потрібно пояснювати
чому це причина, але
ви правильно вгадали
молоді вчені
ми гарантуємо, що вони цього не роблять
здаватися
їх наукової діяльності в україні та
також
інший фокус
розширюється
можливості наших дослідників, оскільки
без
необхідне обладнання та матеріали
неможливо провести
дослідження глобального рівня 2020 року
змінено
наше життя
багато в усьому світі і, звичайно, вчені
не можу
стояти осторонь
і ігнорувати
ці виклики
з якою зіткнулося людство
2020 2021 рік
і тому один із пріоритетів
з нас для нас
дослідження в медицині біотехнологія
приділяємо багато уваги
до
дослідницькі зусилля, які вирішують питання безпеки
проблеми
на національному рівні
я маю на увазі різні рівні безпеки
екологічна інформаційна безпека
до того ж це один із наших пріоритетів
що фонд
фонд контролює та контролює
дослідження того
проводяться в україні
наші головні цілі
коли ми створили національне дослідження
основа
фінансує найкраще
науковий
проекти
які є основними в
рівень програми
ми
використовувати
принципи «знизу вверх».
про що говорили попередні доповідачі і
це гарна європейська традиція
вчені мають вирішувати
що
області, в якій вони повинні спеціалізуватися
слід досліджувати
а потім під час оцінки
експертна оцінка якості цих
зусилля
розвиток дослідницької інфраструктури
і я маю на увазі не лише обладнання
приватний примітив
ми плануємо фінансувати більше
інфраструктурні проекти
і це буде
один із наших пріоритетів